nations and states
that they decided how to respond to copa
based on
california like in other words uh
california culture determined how we
responded to covid more than gavin
newsom
and the swedish culture determined is
why they had a different response to
covid than say
uh
germany
or south korea that these things come
from within they're not imposed by
they're not opposed by
who has less of a role than we think and
culture has more of a role unfortunately
somebody made it virtually impossible
for you to get ivermectin even though it
might have been just the thing to
protect your family is it hard to get
yeah very okay it was confiscated at the
border yeah um your pharmacist your
doctor could say yes this is what you
need prescribe it and your pharmacist
would refuse to fill the prescription
they made it extremely difficult but
whether or not there were school
lockdowns or school closures yep came
from within there was certainly a
uh
patchwork
of different reactions across the
country but certain things were
centralized like thou shall not have
okay yeah yeah so it's complicated yeah
[Music]
welcome to my house thank you
um
thank you for welcoming to me
welcoming me to your house uh
welcome to the dark horse podcast
michael schallenberger thank you brett
what pleasure um we have been traveling
in uh i don't know that circles can be
parallel i have a feeling they can be
but
geometry aside we have been traveling in
parallel circles for some time this is
the first time we have met he's
corresponded a little bit yeah um i
think
the
i'd like to start
by offering you an apology
now i have said this to you privately
but
um i believe i misjudged you
and um
i think it is very important that when
you misjudge a person
that uh you put things right so
the substance of of my misjudging you
has to do with our disagreement which we
still have over nuclear power
you are a strong advocate
for fission power
as a
part or maybe the crucial piece
of the solution to the environmental
problem that you and i both agree is
paramount
you know i think some of our friends on
the right remain to be convinced
of that
but
nonetheless
we have a serious environmental problem
part of it is about the way we fuel our
civilization
and
um the question of whether or not
nuclear power and in particular
uranium-based fusion power plays an
important role in that is a question but
because of your strong advocacy for
nuclear power
i wasn't so sure about you and i have
now seen
you discuss many more topics and
my sense is you know maybe you have
something to teach me about nuclear
power maybe i have something to teach
you um but regardless i read you as
a well-intentioned guy
trying to
get humanity out of a pickle and in that
we are both on that same mission um i i
feel i feel bad that i uh i assumed the
worst of you well thank you very much
well apology accepted
[Music]
um so let's um set the stage a little
bit
many in my audience will be familiar
with you some will not
you are
fresh from a i'm sorry to say a defeat
in your attempt to get into a runoff
with the governor of california um my
condolences i i don't have a vote in
california anymore but had i vote i
certainly would have cast it in your
direction and i advocated that my
my followers and people who pay
attention to me should have done the
same
and i'm sorry it didn't didn't work out
maybe not that surprising in light of
the way
power avoids confrontation with
honorable people
um so in some ways
it saw you coming and it understood
the threat even if others didn't
necessarily know what you had in mind it
could be
this episode is sponsored by american
hartford gold
inflation is at its highest level in 40
years we all feel it at the grocery
store and the fuel pump interest rates
are soaring and retirement accounts are
in real danger
if you want to better protect your
family you should consider that people
have been putting wealth into precious
metals for thousands of years the more
uncertain access to other stores of
value gets the more precious precious
metals are likely to become
call american hartford gold to see how
easy it is to get started
they can show you how to protect your
savings and retirement accounts by
diversifying your portfolio with
physical gold and silver
if you're concerned that sounds a little
retro just call it analog gold and
you're back at the cutting edge
all it takes to get started is a short
phone call and they'll have physical
gold and silver delivered right to your
door or inside your ira or 401k
they are the highest rated firm in the
country with an a plus rating from the
better business bureau and thousands of
satisfied clients
call them now and they will give you a
percentage of your first qualifying
order back in free silver
call american hartford gold at
866-828-1117
that's 866-828-1117
or text darkhorse to 998899
again that's 866-828-1117
or text darkhorse to 998899
and i should also before i let you talk
a little bit about
your experience running for for governor
um i should also point out that uh you
have written a number of books
apocalypse never and uh san francisco
um which every time heather says it she
says san francisco and then has to
correct herself um but uh are these the
only two books you've written i
co-authored a prior book in 2007 but
these are my soul authored two books so
authored books well congratulations um i
have not read both of them but i have
read in both of them and they're they're
quite an interesting read
i would recommend people take a look at
them
so all right what is the experience
we're now what a week out from the
election
less than a week out
um
you know i how am i doing um well
i told you that you know on the one hand
i'm the kind of person that i always
need a goal or project that i'm working
on or i get bored and slightly depressed
so i pretty quickly
you know i we knew that we were
we were unlikely to win because we
weren't raising the money that we needed
to raise so we knew that
about a month ago um
so i spent some time being disappointed
before the election
certainly some disappointment after
i tried to start working on my new book
and i just decided not to
yet i'm gonna have to turn to it soon
but
just basically been binge watching some
television and
continuing my routine you know i started
a serious running routine when i ran
when i decided to run for governor and
i've been maintaining that
and that's been very positive for my
psychological health so i would say i'm
doing i'd say i'm on my right to
recovery
excellent
well um i don't know how much you know
about uh what i was up to during the
last presidential election but i put
together a proposal to get us out of the
death spiral that the
the duopoly has us in
um we also did not succeed you will
notice in uh
disrupting the duopoly's plans and uh
joe biden has has ascended to the office
but nonetheless i do think one of the
meta lessons of the moment for heterodox
thinkers like you and me and andrew yang
and tulsi gabbard and justin amash and
all of those people who have looked at
our system and thought there has to be a
better way
we have to recognize that
effectively power has figured out how to
make itself very difficult to displace
and to the extent that we
patriots who
long for a democracy open enough that
better people could simply ascend to
office and do the right thing based on
the wise counsel of whoever they might
have advised them
that all of us who who see that
need to recognize that it might be time
to team up because each one of us who
tries to do this independently is going
to discover the same thing which is
it's not uh it's not an open system it's
a system that may have a you know a way
to
uh formally enter it but it does not
have a practical way
um so i don't know are you do you know
uh andrew yang
uh we follow each other on twitter but i
don't know yeah we got him um
so and justin amash i mean i know he was
a libertarian presidential candidate but
i don't know personally yeah and chelsea
gabbard same okay yeah so somehow uh you
and i are finally meeting yeah um but
there are many of us out here who
uh
i don't like to use the terms
you know that suggests that these are
enemies but at some level something has
hijacked our democracy and it is doing
terrible things um through uh malignant
governance
and uh maybe maybe it is time we put our
heads together and figured out how to uh
how to dislodge it yeah
um
all right so
nuclear power is the issue on which i
became aware of you first uh do you want
to talk about that or do you want to
start with
your signature issue from from the
campaign
oh sure i mean we could go either i mean
um i was you got anything about politics
just now and uh just to affirm
it's a very hard question i mean i think
there's some questions around what is
the question
um and what what is important for us to
talk about
i've certainly spent a bunch of time
about homelessness it's not much time
about nuclear
you're asking some questions i i think
what i hear you asking about our
questions around how do we translate
this really exciting interesting
uh heterodoxical movement that
that once was known as the idw and may
still be known by some of us that are
loyal to ibw but how does that translate
into political change
i have friends on the political right
who
think that i am
deeply naive for attempting to be an
independent
uh
dave rubin chris rufo
are friends of mine that are now fully
republican
um dave is
uh i believe he's a trump supporter
um
and chris uh rufo works closely with
governor desantis in florida
i have
other friends close friends family that
just think republicans are evil i think
that trump is a would-be dictator
we talked a little bit before uh i voted
for clinton and biden i did not vote for
trump
i do not there's things about trump i do
not like there's other things about
trump that i actually appreciate
including
changing the republican party's position
on entitlements changing the republican
party's position on gay and lesbian
uh affirming gay and lesbian
relationships
and taking a stronger position against
military intervention abroad
but there's other things the way he
spoke about women the way he spoke about
disabled people
his some of the personality stuff
and the chaos
there's a lot of big clown energy
in trump that i think was
destructive and not and we needed some
stability stability which is why i voted
for biden but obviously biden i think
you and i would probably agree has been
a terrible
president
um so what do we do
well let me just say yeah biden has been
a an absolute disaster
a predictable one i didn't vote for him
um i didn't vote for trump either did
you go for justin awash no i voted for
tulsi gabbard okay um yeah you know the
fact is and and this is something i
believe
people in your possession in my position
need to confront others who are fed up
with our system over i know far too many
incredibly smart people who have arrived
at what i think is the incredibly
foolish choice
to
not vote
and the problem
as i see it is that when you don't vote
you become indistinguishable from all
the people who don't vote because
they're apathetic
and i get that you don't have a vote in
front of you that makes sense and that
you personally may feel that you're
protesting by not voting but why would
you deny the power of your vote to all
of those of us who are trying to figure
out how to dislodge the duopoly before
it's too late right so my point would be
a protest but an actual protest vote ha
is very powerful potentially if enough
of them you know most of us are fed up
if we were to actually allow ourselves
to be counted as something different
than apathetic that we would be a force
to be reckoned with yeah but i'm also
disappointed that when somebody like
yourself
stands up
and you know
takes the risk of daring
to you know run in the open for governor
what i hoped would happen what i tried
to get to happen uh by
trying to call attention to your
candidacy on twitter was i hoped that
all of the people that we are in
conversation with would stand up and say
hey this is the moment right this is the
moment for a real challenge to be made
and um
you know there were a few who did but i
i must say i was disappointed not to see
the
you know i hate the term influencer i
think it's a terrible term and the
problem is
influencers are not leaders and we need
leaders but all of the people in the
vast heterodox influencer group i think
could have made the difference and
well let me say something about the run
because um
the you you were right to detect an
opportunity um which is that we have an
open primary system in california so
it's the top two vote getters and it
means anybody can vote for anybody so
democrats can vote for republicans
republicans vote for democrats and
anybody over independent iran as an
independent which in california is
called new party preference yep
so the opportunity here was to and we
had a weak republican field so the
opportunity here was that everyone
assumes the governor would come in first
and there's an opportunity to come in
second i came in third
it looks like i'll probably have around
four percent of the vote and my uh and
the person that will that came in second
will have something like 13
there was a scenario to get
to be in second but we needed a lot more
money
and we got in uh we got in late i was
intending to
back the former mayor of san diego he
decided not to run because he didn't
think he could win
and that wasn't he didn't decide not to
run until january so i only got into the
race in early march
so we had three months so long story
short we didn't have the money we didn't
have the time
i don't think we should be i mean i
think one question is and you know what
if we had more money could we have come
in second i think so
if we'd come in second could we have won
in the general
i think it was a chat
um would have still been difficult but
we would have done better than the 40
that the 38 to 40 of the republicans
always get in california
so i just want to lay that out there
because i think
we don't want to overread what happened
here
and then i think it's also more
challenging at the federal level with
the presidential election than it is in
open primary state i was disappointed
i'll take something i was disappointed
because the whole time i'm campaigning
andrew yang is talking about the need
for a third party candidate
and he never endorsed me now i didn't go
asking for it either so it's not like
i'm not crying about it but i thought it
was a little weird like here you have
somebody who is actually running an open
primary
and we didn't and andrew yang's out
there talking in the abstract
so for me it was not it was not it
wasn't i wasn't upset about it it was
more weird like why would you talk
abstractly about supporting somebody
independent rather than actually
supporting somebody that was independent
well
a number of things that there are four
or five things in there that i think
yeah need a response one of them is
i think trump did us one huge service
which was that he demonstrated that the
duopoly could be beaten even at the top
level right and he did that under the
red banner but he basically um
commandeered the republican party over
the objection of the power brokers and
demonstrated that they could not outfox
him now i think he was
you know the very same character traits
that allowed him to do that made him the
wrong guy for the job right for sure
right but nonetheless the knowledge that
it is possible
is
very interesting yeah and with respect
to your point about andrew yang in
particular and i must say i have not met
andrew in person he and i have
corresponded and i consider him a friend
and i greatly appreciate what he's doing
yeah um
but
his failure to show up
uh for you i think is emblematic of a
larger issue
which is
the kinds of people who break first who
enter this world and start trying to
think outside the box about what you
know could you come in second in a
california open primary and then once
you have the attention of the public
because who is this person who came in
second you you know you could at least
change the conversation if not be
elected to the office that's a pretty
clever ploy right right i mean i don't
mean to use the word ploy
yeah yeah sure it's actually it's tactic
there's an opening in california yeah
wouldn't it have been marvelous if this
had worked yeah um but you got to be a
little bit of a lone wolf to think that
way right and so you have lone wolf
disease i have long wolf disease so does
andrew yang justin
yeah gabriel so the problem is
all of the people who see this
opportunity before it's obvious
are also people who have a little
trouble confederating
and
a little trouble well that's something
like idw as the uh that's supposed to be
the banner but nobody liked adw so
well look i think idw
you know personally i hope i don't get
myself in trouble with my brother who
coined the term but um
my sense is that idw was a prototype and
that effectively
the mission becomes how do we make the
2.0 version and the 3.0 version until we
get something that self-catalyzes at a
level that it actually can
build power responsibly
um and you know i thought it was a very
responsible group but it was a you know
it was an abstraction
and in order to do what you were talking
about for example or what i was talking
about with unity 2020 or what andrew
yang is talking about with the forward
party
you have to be
um
you know i'll borrow from from the
christians right
you have to be in the world but not of
it you have to be strategically minded
enough to play the political game
without allowing a political game to
take you over yes and i very much i mean
i don't know why i mean eric came out
strongly for you yes but you and your
brother did that was great yeah but the
question is
there are a lot of people who have a lot
of influence
who i think weren't sure what to make of
you and so it was just easier to say
nothing yeah and i really wish that they
had realized it is inexpensive to say i
don't know this person there might be
something about them that is off but
they look good to me and
they could hardly be worse than what
we've got oh sure or even doing this
you're gonna need a zoom call for me
that's super cheap
right well you know i mean i guess or
listen to the six hours of joe rogan
that we recorded i mean those you know
we did a lot of a lot of podcasts
but yeah i think you're right um
i was gonna say
i think there's a bigger i think one of
the questions is
is there room for a third
space i don't want to say party
necessarily because i think just saying
aside that but even pre-politically
rss you know i was telling you i was
watching this uh
this uh
netflix tv series called boredom about
parliamentary system in europe yeah
what's so fascinating is that you know
the the parliamentary elections and then
they form a government
with multiple parties in a coalition
government sure so you can be um you can
get five percent of the vote
and have a lot of sway
over what a government does and so take
the greens of europe the greens the most
famous thing of course is that they
got i mean here germany um and we can
get into nuclear i don't mean to make
this about nuclear but the greens have
exerted extraordinary influence in terms
of energy policy over center-left
political coalitions by being a small
minority yep
in the united states um
there is some of that right you have aoc
you have the kind of you have minority
uh political minorities exerting some
power within a political coalition but
you're still sort of either democrat or
republican
and so one question is is that just
baked in to the system or is there a
room for a third and i thought about
that the promise of the idw
was that it was saying
we're not going to be classified as
liberal or conservative as republican or
democrat so for me that was my initial
attraction to it i saw people pushing
back
on a set of
pushing back mostly to be fair on the
radical left but also not aligning with
trump and trumpism
and barry weiss's article in the new
york times magazine is is uh i think you
were in yeah um you know sort of you joe
rogan claire layman
um
you know but it also had people like ben
shapiro who's clearly a republican
clearly conservative
so for me that was always exciting
though because it was like there was a
space that was being formed now it seems
like there's been some conflicts within
that space
there's been some amanda that you know
there was some conflicts around trump
there were conflicts around covid
trump strained it and trump and code
were probably the biggest two issues
um
maybe we'll have disagreements by
nuclear we can certainly get into them i
don't hesitate to do that but to say
for me the initial excitement of it was
that there is this disruptive third path
and it seems like i want to continue to
try to hold that but it seems like a set
of other folks in there are like they're
like we're out and we don't want to do
it well look
i think we have to not over interpret
the effect of trump and then covid on
something like the idw you know
painting with a broad brush id was the
right idw was the right idea and we can
see that you know it's one thing people
are sometimes freaked out if you start
at idw because what is this you know
this the the name
throws people immediately
but
the hidden tribes report
says that there is a vast group in the
middle and russia
hidden tribes is
it's a it's a report that came out of a
study group in which they surveyed
political attitudes of americans and
what they found is what they call um the
exhausted middle which is a
substantial majority of us agree on most
things even the things that we are
famously unable to agree on we basically
agree on do we basically agree on
abortion you know very few people want
to do it you know close to conception
and very few people want to tolerate it
close to birth which means we have to
draw a line and it's not going to be a
comfortable one but most americans are
right in the you know growing mindset
and the point is issue after issue we
are this way
now
that stands in stark contrast to what
happens at the ballot box which has
increasingly become about teams
right where we you know we are on a
razor thin margin between blue and red
and we can't we don't barely see the
other side as human and the point is
that is actually a distraction from the
real process of
uh of governing and
i would argue by some kind of design
whether that design is intentional and
conspiratorial or whether it's
evolutionary and emergent something has
kept us divided so that our true power
is never manifest in government and i
you know i would argue that
what effectively happened
was
during the clinton administration
the democratic party
shifted strategies and what it did was
it went from being a representative of
working people
um and you know was it a clean
representative no the unions were dirty
and there was all kinds of
uh corrupt politics going on but
basically the democratic party
represented working people and then and
the republican party represented
corporate uh interests and
the clinton administration
caused the democratic party to become a
direct competitor to the republican
party and their real constituents became
a different subset of the corporations
and the american public was shut out and
we've been playing political theater
ever since right the point is there is
no party that represents the american
people
were there one it would be wildly
popular
and that raises the question about why
nobody ever builds one right and
um
the
you know you say is there room for a
third party and we've got parliamentary
systems and is there something about the
structure of our first past the post
voting that makes it impossible to have
a third well i do think that a third is
unstable but a second would be good
because really what we have are two
you know slightly different flavors of
the very same
corrupt system and no representative of
the people and so you know the
the politicos effectively
deal with the electorate as an annoyance
right they have to answer to us every so
often enough to win power that they then
pedal to their actual constituents
um and you know
who loses we do
so
yes idw is the way to talk about it
doesn't have to be idw it could be any
group of people that's willing to put
aside large differences in order just to
have an honest conversation
um
and yes there's room for something
political but one has to you're not
going to go through the front door
that's that's the thing we all keep
learning and what is the what is what is
not going through the front door look
like
well like the open priority i mean open
primary is a great example some
alternative
well i would say at the point that they
instituted an open primary they created
a shift in a strategic opportunity that
maybe they hadn't noticed
you noticed it
right it's like oh
i've got to come in second and then we
have a head-to-head race between
you know the name brand candidate and
the maverick and that's at least
interesting right so yeah you noticed a
strategic opportunity i did something
related with unity 2020 which was
there's a reason that you can't win the
presidency from a third party position
at the moment and that's because
any time you try no matter who the major
party candidates are you are accused of
endangering the republic by
uh spoiling the election and throwing it
to the greater evil
so unity 2020 was a very carefully
architected plan to avoid that critique
right a center left candidate a center
right candidate who would agree
draft these two people based on their
their uh
capacity right their
integrity um and their courage
and
they would agree to govern as a team
and only when they couldn't reach
agreement only when they couldn't come
to consensus would the person in the
president's role
make the call and then after four years
they would run in the reverse positions
so the point is everything about that
plan
was about neutralizing the asymmetry
between right and left and
you know given a fair shot most people
would like some courageous capable
patriots in the white house talking
about every issue figuring out what's in
the american public's interest and
taking their best shot right that's got
to be better than what we have
right yeah so
so anyway that is also a strategic
loophole right in other words we have a
system in which we elect a president and
a vice president but nothing says that
you can't between those two have an
informal agreement to do something else
now andrew yang got pretty far through
the front door right
well no
you didn't think you got very far i
thought he
i mean he noticed a loophole too or
maybe
something did which was
that
effectively you could mount a campaign
on social media and goliath didn't
understand social media well enough to
stop it
but what happened to andrew yang is that
he got stopped by the major media right
right you remember the nonsense where
they put up in you know when they were
like showing the chart of how well the
different candidates in the democratic
field were doing and in andrew yang's
place they put up some
randomly chosen asian man oh i don't
remember that and you know during the
debates they cut off his mic i mean it
was low-level power games
that that stopped him
but you know okay
and then you know justin amash he's
really interesting when you talk to him
about what life actually looked like
inside the u.s house of representatives
and how different it is and how
virtually impossible it is for your
representative to make anything occur in
that body because of the way power has
been reapportioned through
changes
so i don't know it sort of seems like
we've got
we've got a puzzle that's more
a question of can you strategically
figure out what the enemy hasn't
anticipated and and find a way to
actually
you know
squeeze through the cracks then hey
people are sick of this let's
let's run and win right right that
should work but it doesn't yeah
yeah i mean it seems like you know the
the
the challenge this translates a
translation problem from cultural
formation like we're calling idw to
political viability and what was so
striking for me as somebody that was
outside politics was how powerful
identity is
so there's just a lot of people
even though like i have been on fox news
joe rogan you know i got bill maher at
the end
um
my books have sold to republicans
republicans go to the ballot box and
they go who's the republican guy
you know there's just still
and partly that's because we did not
reach enough people but i was more
famous than the republican i had more
twitter you know more social media
followers more publicity than the
republican but because he was the
republican guy
the voters
i is sided with the republicans so
there's an identity problem here too
that i was struck by similarly in the
recall election a fairly no-name
democrat but the most high-profile
democrat who ran
had more votes than the most qualified
republican who's the former mayor of san
diego so identity is so powerful and
these party names of course these party
identities are super old so i'm struck
by how much of the problem is in
the political structures themselves and
how much of it is just in the
consciousness of the voters which is
very very low i mean people think about
the products they buy more than they
think about the political parties and
the candidates yeah
well i agree although there's another
loophole that is to me
uh glaring
which i thought it did not
you know i watched at a distance the
struggle that you were facing in this
election and
you know i hesitate to say this into a
camera because i don't necessarily want
goliath to understand it but here's the
thing goliath is kind of an obstacle i
don't think he's going to get it even if
i have this blind right that's the whole
point or he's very nearsighted
well i mean you know my riff on this is
that goliath modern so
there was a goliath a real guy who
probably had a pituitary tumor right and
that's why he was a giant um he wasn't
defeated by david he was defeated by a
guy named el hanon but anyway
it's probably a true story and the point
is these pituitary tumor giants
are feeble they're powerful but they're
feeble right and goliath our goliath is
a composite it's you know they're
you know people who meet inside the dnc
and presumably the rnc and conspire
right but there's also this emergent
property that's very powerful but the
thing about emerging properties
like all products of evolution they're
really powerful against things that
assembled them
they're moronic when it comes to
fighting things they've never seen
before right so
being novel and coming at them from a
direction they don't expect is is key
yes but anyway the glaring
opportunity that i see that i don't
think um
most of us yet get
is
this was an election in california
now it happens that i'm a californian
by birth
but i don't live in california
right why was i voicing an opinion about
a california election and the answer is
well a
california belongs to me too yeah right
i may move back here even if i never do
i'm an american and california is an
important part of america and i have an
interest in what happens here all right
i do not want to see it collapse i also
have
almost all of my family lives in
california so i have an interest here
that way even if i didn't
let's say i was jordan peterson right
and i'm in canada i still don't want
california to fail it's part of the west
right right and so anyway my point would
be
i think that in order to do what you
were doing
less focus on
you know the focus on what to do with
california if you win the seat
yeah that's important yeah but who needs
to recognize you as an important player
in that
they don't have to be californians yes i
agree no we wanted and
is it i'm glad you raised it that was
that was the way i felt too is that this
is important for the country california
is super important for the dr i mean so
many things start in california and they
move east
so i totally agree with that um
let me ask it this way what would have
done that what more would have done that
just slightly more vision on the part of
our friends frankly yeah just more
endorsements and stuff yeah
i guess the point is look it's very very
inexpensive to say you know
to say what i said or what eric said oh
yeah the point was
do i know this guy backwards and
forwards i don't but i can see what's in
the office and i can see that this guy
is way clearer headed
and
why wouldn't
you know given that we've got a machine
politician yeah doing what the machine
wants and that it's obviously a disaster
which you can you don't have to drive
very many blocks to see it it's exact
visible right why would we take a gamble
on something different right what are
the chances we could actually do worse
yeah i think they're actually pretty low
so
you know who in particular were you
surprised
that you didn't see
speak out it wasn't even that what i was
hoping would happen is that there would
be a
active conversation amongst those people
right and that basically
i mean look i'm coming from
having
watched um when heather and i released
our book last september
we were
probably as a result of
our heterodox stance on covid and the
response to it
completely frozen out by
mainstream media
um
and censored too right
utterly censored and slandered i mean we
are slandered to this day on our
wikipedia pages of things yeah but the
point is the book
still
got into the
top five new york times
bestsellers across all categories right
how did that happen
it happened
because a whole network of people who
aren't supposed to matter actually
matter more right in the mainstream
media right right and so if
that wide group of people you know from
russell brand and england to jordan
peterson you know if that yeah extended
network of people had said we're all
concerned about california we're all
intrigued that there's somebody running
who isn't one of the mainstream
offerings i mean you know you're on the
dark horse podcast you're a true dark
horse
right yeah that's what you are and um if
there had been a recognition hey it is a
moment for a dark horse candidate to to
show up and you know frankly
i wouldn't want to be governor of
california
they've set you up that's a bad that's a
bad set of responsibilities to be handed
at this moment because they've already
done a good job of uh wrecking the
system so
you know not only do you have to steward
it well but you have to steer it well
enough to get it out of a tailspin right
yeah it would be a tough job right but
nonetheless here's you know i'm sitting
on a couch with a guy who actually
looked at that and didn't say yeah
not for me you said okay yeah i'll do it
absolutely yeah i mean i think um it's
interesting i think that the people that
did not
do more to support my candidacy
i think were mostly on the political
right
and they tended to be people who had
given up on california
including people that had moved
and i think had i would say people that
have either given up on the on the um on
california
given up and then to some extent given
up on politics
and are skeptical that much can be
achieved in politics whereas the people
that were supportive
they weren't all on the left but i
associate you and your brother even
though your covet position i i think of
you as more center left now maybe that's
not a label you would use i describe
myself as a reluctant radical and what
that means is i believe only radical
change will save us radical changes
frightening but i don't think we have a
choice okay i i'm not center left okay
your brother
is more centered left over he's closer
to the center yeah yeah um
so i think people
now are there are other people like ayan
hercia lee neil ferguson who are
probably conservative
um
uh peter bogosian our mutual friend in
portland i think he would define himself
as a liberal he does
and would probably be like a social
democrat in europe or something yeah um
so i think he was enthusiastic uh
melissa chen has become a friend she's
uh i think she's
she's at a conservative magazine but
is probably pretty center left if you
really look at her policy agenda um
so you know i mean i think those are the
folks i think the folks that are fully
republican
that are skeptical of a third way
that are that have renounced idw are
skeptical of ibw were the ones who did
not show up to be supportive
so yeah i mean i think it's um
i mean look i think i'm mostly happy
there's a way in which i kind of think
it's good that i didn't know
how little support we would have gotten
which was good we got good support but
i'm glad we didn't know how we've gotten
in advance otherwise i wouldn't have run
right and by running we were able to
force this issue
you know the coverage has changed of
homelessness in particular it's gone
from being viewed pretty narrowly as a
housing affordability issue
to an untreated
addiction mental illness issue
and if anything i think the coverage is
still
it's much more balanced now i would say
than before we're now seeing in seattle
they're shutting down the homeless
encampment slash open drug scenes
i'm not sure where the portland
conversation is at but it does seem like
some of it's changing i think you did
change the conversation and i think that
was
hugely important i think you
substantially change the kind that makes
me feel happy yeah
i i feel it and i also have one
observation to make you know it's very
hard to see outside of your own uh i
don't want to say bubble but even just
your own circumstance yes something that
i think was invisible to you
um which i wish i had conveyed earlier
but it took me a while to figure it out
is that part of what happened to you was
that nobody who wasn't in california had
any idea
what the actual
mechanism of the race meant about timing
right so the point was i don't think
people understood
that june 7th was the date on which they
would have needed to show up
to matter yeah right because they
thought they were looking at november
right exactly yeah and
so if
this could you know yeah i'm dreaming of
a of a of a white paper that could be
sent out that says look
here's the candidate
here is why this is actually
uh potentially viable yeah here's the
date that matters right here you know
whatever the other parameters might be
and then
um and then the question is can you
get people out of the you know we are
all so used to being burned
by
what we didn't know about the article we
read that we tweeted or whatever it is
everybody is so on edge about making
errors that i think it's just far easier
when you see you know i don't know what
a michael schallenberger is and i don't
really understand how it is that he's
running for governor
it's easiest just not to touch the issue
yep right yeah yeah that makes sense
um
well this is good i want to talk about
so i want to come i think we can we can
come back to nuclear at the end i'd like
to talk a little about cough is let's um
and censorship um so i
stayed out of codebit for the most part
i wrote some early i run an early piece
that's basically was
pretty much echoing the mainstream view
which was that we needed to take some
pretty significant actions yeah this was
in march april
2020. and then i decided to go write san
francisco and i basically stopped
working on it for the campaign
i had a lot of people that were and you
may know that steve kirsh is on my board
my non-profit oh yeah so steve curtis is
a long time friend and supporter has
been on my board of directors and i know
he's a friend of yours now
um
but i knew very little about it i stayed
most out of it i saw that you and claire
were fighting
i saw this thing going i was trying to
be nice
yeah
um
so
you know i'm interested in how you look
back on the last couple of years and
what you take from it um i will say i
have been censored on facebook for
climate information
um and then the only time i've ever been
censored on instagram was just
a week ago
for
for posting images of my tweets
saying that mass mandates were
pseudoscience and what i tweeted out was
from the new york times it was from
david leonard his piece on mass mandates
so the only i've ever had censored
catch me tell me where what what
when you look back for the last two
years
and and also just catch me with your
views because i know i'm sure you're you
know i know your viewers know but but
yeah looking back and how would you
summarize it
um
yeah i mean
there are a couple different threads
there yeah one
personally
i don't think i had any choice about
what i did i'm sure there are small
things i could alter there are a couple
things i got wrong which i i wish i
hadn't but i thought
actually in light of how much one could
get wrong that actually
we got almost everything right okay and
that that's important but i mean
basically
when i
when i came into the public eye i came
into the public eye
for being the person who faced with an
accusation of racism
just said no no that's not true right
i can establish that if you're willing
to listen
and so the point is i got famous as it
were for
saying difficult true things yes that's
what i always do right right and the
problem is sometimes
it wins you
friends
and then it will turn some of those
people to enemies on the next topic
right and my feeling is look
you either signed up for somebody who
will do that
in which case you know there's nothing
that guards me against being wrong other
than the fact that i try really hard not
to be wrong because
frankly reversing course is
painful and right costly
um
but you know you're either signed up for
somebody who will say the uncomfortable
stuff no matter how many people disagree
with them and no matter how forcefully
or you're not really on board with that
and so my feeling is okay
i did what i always do
in this case
it had um
terrible effects
in many regards i mean heather and i
lost
more than half our family income in a
single hour as youtube demonetized both
our channels they remain demonetized wow
um for things that we were right about
right
um so they need a best-selling book
best-selling book we don't know how well
it would have done if we hadn't been
actively accused of spreading
misinformation which has now been
redefined
um by the federal government by the
department of homeland security as mal
information have you have you gotten the
memo
no
there are now three types of
informational terrorism
one of them is misinformation that's
when you're incorrect about something
the next one is disinformation that's
when you're incorrect and you know it
intentionally and mal information is
when you're correct in a way that causes
distrust of the government
so that might be where you ended up
running afoul of uh instagram or wow
well
so back me up in terms of
um all right what did you get right what
did you get wrong and what is the jury
so out about on
okay
well there's a question about what the
evidence says yeah there's a question
about what
people have now acknowledged and there
are big gaps here so okay i would say
that there are um
several major threads to the
conversation
the first one is
um where did the virus come from
uh
i was very early on lab week
um
i won't go all the way back into the
history but it became obvious very
quickly
that
while some of the evidence was ambiguous
all of the evidence that wasn't
ambiguous pointed to the lab and not to
the wet market or to a cave okay and you
know i said so okay um
and i was pretty clear that the street
you know i wasn't 100 sure of anything
but um so the three big issues
origin
there's origin masks and
masks
lockdowns
and vaccines are those would you say
those are the four big issues really no
i would say the three biggest issues are
origin
early treatment and vaccine safety and
effectiveness okay i would say there is
a fourth that the public has yet to
really understand
is even an issue but it is which is uh
the evolution of
viral variants rarely coming from why do
they look the way they do what would we
do if we wanted to shut them down right
um so that's a fourth thread and then
there's the lockdown and math question
masks are actually one thing i got wrong
early on i thought i was one of the
first people uh anywhere that i was
aware of who was masking in fact
at the point that covid
became it became clear covet was going
to transform the way we were interacting
at least for the time being
we we had a our studio was downtown and
my son and i would go
late at night when we wouldn't interact
with anybody
um and we would we took all of the
equipment to do our podcast out of this
office space that we knew we were
abandoning and we moved it into our
house and we would go to the home depot
and we would buy the stuff for our set
and we built this thing
and
i got a reputation
as the bandit of the hardware store
because i was masking
right nobody else was masking anything
this is all in portland yeah nobody's
masking in portland early on no no no i
was masked way before they were and is
your view now that masks are you i mean
do like n95s or you think n95s don't
work uh i wouldn't say n95s don't work i
would say if properly worn n95 masks
have some effect right but the mask
mandates don't require an end 95 yeah
cloth masks don't seem to work at all i
was struck on social media how how much
people mixed up masks and mask mandates
right there they're the same thing and
they're not um
right so okay so that's easy so then so
then what about the vaccines well hold
on masks i got wrong okay um
lockdowns i think i got right
which was there was a place for
lockdowns but they needed to be
more intense than they were
they needed to be short duration and
needed to be paired with excellent
quality testing which frankly we still
don't have right which i don't know i
can't imagine why we don't have it i
think that's a problem money would solve
and the fact that we haven't dedicated
enough money to have tests that are
worth anything is conspicuous to me but
i would have had let's say a yes painful
six-week very intense lockdown and the
reason for that is that that gives it
enough time most of the transmission
wasn't home so six weeks gives it enough
time to burn through
you know places where we are corralled
together
such that at the point you lift that six
week mandate you have a small number of
places where active covet still exists
and if you had good testing you could
figure out where they were and you could
apply some very local solutions that we
the rest of us could have gone back
um to life
given that we never had good tests i
would not favor that plan but
were i in charge i would have invested
very an asian east asian approach korea
hong kong well
yes and no
you know
good
uh good tests would be key
and then a epidemiologically sensible
lockdown in which the virus was given a
chance to be not contagious in any given
group
so that
you know you would have hot spots but
you could find them and the rest of us
wouldn't be infecting each other so i
think i had that right but we don't know
okay we didn't do that okay
um
lab origin i think i clearly had right
and i think almost everybody now gets it
so the other two are early treatment and
vaccines early treatment vaccines and
you asked for vaccines first yeah um
i initially was excited about the
vaccines i initially assumed that i
would be vaccinated
i became and heather and i really became
immediately alarmed at the point that
the vaccines were announced because of
what was said about them right heather
and i because we're biologists looked at
what we were being told about these
vaccines and on the one hand
what a marvelous
fascinating way to vaccinate right this
is a really radically different way of
inducing an immune response and you know
in our book which was finished we
literally emerged from writing the last
uh or the
first
uh draft of the book that we then
submitted to the publisher
we emerged we were in the
ecuador and amazon figuring
finalizing the book we emerged back to
where our phones connected to the world
and heard about uh the novel coronavirus
and so anyway the book was written
before
comet it has an addendum that includes
kelby but the book is not about cobit
and
in the book we say vaccination is one of
three great triumphs of medical
technology right the other two being
surgery and antibiotics
so we're big fans of vaccines and these
vaccines are
really fascinating and we were compelled
that it was a pretty interesting idea
but we were absolutely alarmed at being
told that they were safe
because they couldn't possibly be
right we didn't know that they did harm
but the point is safe means you know it
doesn't do harm
and the gamble involved in this radical
intervention
in
the immune system
uh was so great that i thought well
you're you're telling us you know that
these aren't going to cause
autoimmune disorders or
tumors or neurological disruptions
right it was just the number of things
that these could induce
that you would have to you would need
years following them to know for sure
that they didn't do it and we were told
oh no they're they're safe and we know
it right accelerated the process of
testing these are safe and it's like
well i know you just lied to me right
and so the fact that they lied to us and
said they were safe when they couldn't
possibly know that
caused us to think
we want you know we weren't initially
eligible um because we're healthy and uh
not that old and so we were like okay
we'll wait as long as we can and we'll
give time for an adverse event signal to
show up because that's the safer thing
to do and the longer we waited the more
frightening that picture became right
so
what is the state of this discussion
well
i don't think most of the public has any
idea yet
how
much harm has been done
right i don't think the public has
caught on to the fact that
we either have no information on how
dangerous they are because the one
system we have for collecting that
information is now dismissed
um or we do know how dangerous they are
and it's incredibly dangerous but we
have an adverse event signal that is
greater than all of the other vaccines
combined you know over the course of 30
years so the signal we built a system to
detect an adverse event signal
that
that system
is firing off you know alarms at an
unprecedented level and we're ignoring
it
now the public does know about
myocarditis and it knows about blood
clots and so it knows that there's some
sort of an issue but it hasn't yet
understood how deep the problem is
um
hopefully we will stop gaslighting the
injured
you know and find out how many there are
find out how sick they are and find out
whether we can treat them
but for the moment we're still
pretending that it's a tiny tiny number
of people which
seems very unlikely
and then there's the toughest of all of
these which is
early treatment
so we were effectively told that there
was
um
you know you could either
face covet
or
you could be vaccinated
well that's only because we ignored
the medicines that really do work right
and what white i mean i i said steve
kirsh was advocated this of course i saw
the 60 minutes
that covered one of these trials which
was right here in berkeley by the way at
the local
um
horse
uh arena where the workers remember this
yeah yeah the uh the workers got these
two different early treatments so for
flu boxing yeah yeah so what like what's
the deal there well
the deal is unfortunately
um
of a nature
that
you know
there are two mutually exclusive ways of
viewing it either those of us who
believe early treatment works
are all
woefully misinformed
and
incapable of seeing that we've made an
error
or
something has endeavored
has spent mightily to prevent
information
on early treatments that work from
making it to your doctor your pharmacist
you know the mainstream media
i don't think this is ambiguous at all
the evidence is
quite strong
but
the
sophistication of the campaign that has
been marshaled to prevent that
information from being understood
is
stunning but it was on i mean fluoxamine
zesty luxamine fluoxamine was once it
was on 60 minutes and it was incredibly
compelling so what happened with that
particular that's a great question
because here okay so we've got
fluvoxamine which is uh
usually used for depression
um we've got a strong signal that it is
very effective against covid
um
it's not part of the standard of care
and why is that
because there's no money to be made it's
the obvious answer because it's a
generic at this point is that why yeah
is it the story is the story i've read
the story where sort of one of the
reasons they
that they thought that these drugs were
that fluvoxamine or other psychiatric
drugs would work was because psychiatric
patients were not getting covered is
that yours is that a sort of urban myth
um i don't know steve would be the guy
yeah to ask about that um i have not
been particularly excited about
fluvoxamine because i think
by and large you know these
psychological medications are a faustian
bargain and we have better drugs we have
drugs that work better than that what
are those um
here's where things get very ugly yeah
there are two primary and then there are
a bunch of other things that seem to
contribute okay the two are irmectin and
hydroxychloroquine okay
now hydroxychloroquine is one i got
wrong
i did not spot that early i thought i
bought the story right at the point that
trump talked about hydroxychloroquine
and then
you know
the scientific chorus erupted and said
it doesn't work we thought it was
promising but it doesn't work i assumed
that that made sense it turns out it
doesn't it's a very important anti-cova
drug with very low toxicity and the
tests that were done actually
specifically gave people a toxic dose in
order
to make the uh
the compound
unthinkable um but it does it does
there's very strong evidence that
hydroxychloroquine is very effective
against covid
um
there is equally strong evidence
that ivermectin works
ivermectin has two
utilities in this crisis one of them is
that it is extremely effective at
treating people who have covid now the
earlier you give it the better and one
of the ways that the
uh evidence for its utility has been
obscured
is by making what are called
underpowered trials that do things like
treat people with too little or treat
them too late in the course of the
disease for it to be effective
but if you treat people early with a
sufficient dose iremectin turns out to
be very effective at keeping people from
getting severely ill
and it's extremely low toxicity
so there's
effectively no reason not to give it and
it's been used effectively in many parts
of the world
to control the pandemic
now the really interesting thing about
it is because it's so safe as a drug and
it really is among the safest drugs that
we have
um it can be given
without
a positive covered test in other words
if you think you have covid
we can just give it to you
we're not putting you at significant
risk what's more because it has
prophylactic effectiveness we can give
it to the people you live with and keep
them from getting sick
so
i did get one thing wrong with
ivermectin which was i put too much
weight on a study that came out of
argentina which said
the study was
over a thousand people and it appeared
to be a hundred percent effective
and i thought well
that's pretty powerful evidence
there was then some concern about the
quality of the data
i didn't want to get it wrong so i
actually contacted the primary
investigator i said can i see the data
set
he did not provide the data set and i
became further along that there was
something about this study that
was unreliable i believe we now know
what happened which was that
uh
this uh researcher hector carvajal ran
the study but he ran it as a tally he
didn't keep the data in the way that a
proper scientific experiment would what
he basically did was counted
case numbers of
cases of covet and it's sloppy
so when i discovered that that was the
case i went to my audience and i said
look i have
said that this study suggests that this
is nearly 100 effective as a
prophylactic i would now rate the
quality of the study you know i would
give it to zero evidentiary weight and
that changes the overall picture for
iron mechanisms value a bit but not much
so
i got that wrong and i got
hydroxychloroquine wrong and i got masks
wrong
um
but
other than that
i think i got just about everything
right and so what's the um and so you're
what would your and what do your critics
accuse you of
um and what is your response to your
critics
my response to my critics is that they
don't actually know what they're talking
about but what is their criticism what
is their criticism of you and what's
that the criticism
uh the one that is most intense
at this point is
you got ivermectin wrong we now know it
doesn't work
and you uh for reasons of pride or
because
you've made money or something like this
won't admit it
now frankly
even at this late date if i thought
ivory beckham didn't work the best thing
i could do for my family for my future
would be to say hey i got this one wrong
here's how it happened but it doesn't
work
it's just not the case it does work and
the fact that people have been
um kept from having access to this drug
and then been left with a choice do you
want to be vaccinated or not when the
real choice is of the available
treatments and preventatives
which is the best
from the point of view of the cost
benefit analysis
right
likely
for almost everybody and maybe even for
everybody these vaccines were far too
radical in their mechanism of action to
be contemplated and for most people they
could be kept safe with these
alternatives
the problem is there wasn't any money to
be made and so is the
is the disagreement about the evidence
turn on this issue of the under
of not prescribing ivermectin soon
enough or at high enough dosages
well have you heard of the together
trial no okay you you probably did run
across it at the point that it finally
emerged so the together trial was a
complex trial that tested many different
drugs including
phlebox or at least the primary evidence
anyway tested many drugs against placebo
and supposedly we knew
eight months ago now
that the result for ivermectin did not
was not um
statistically
they used a different kind of statistics
but it was not statistically significant
in favor of either mecca which is not
the same thing as saying iremected
doesn't work
but it is
uh a negative result right
we didn't see the study for seven months
we saw the headline we saw you know
slides from a powerpoint presentation
that said no ivermectin is not effective
at keeping people uh
safe and keeping them from getting very
sick seven months later
the
um
the actual paper is published and we're
able to finally scrutinize what was done
and it's insane right i mean there are
things built into this trial that
still have not been explained that
absolutely sabotage it right there's a
weight cut off
for the dosing so the dosage that the
paper says that they give is a viable
dose but they cut it off and they don't
keep increasing it the heavier you are
and so the point is what this does is it
takes people who are the most vulnerable
to kovid
and underdoses them right
so
anyway the point is
the public got
the headline
seven months before they got the paper
they read the title of the paper they
read the abstract but until you get to
the method section and start asking
questions about well what exactly was
done in the study and what effect would
that have on a drug that works it
dramatically underpowered the trial
what's more
the evidence that the together trial
produced does suggest that ivermectin is
effective in fact the pi who who's the
first author on this paper
says that he believes if they had added
more patience to the trial they would
have shown a positive effect for
ivermectin right he says it's a matter
of the size of the study not the
effectiveness of the drug you said that
to steve pershing an email
okay so
this is
not evidence that people that people
think it is of the drug's
ineffectiveness it's evidence of what
happens if you underpower a trial with
an effective drug is you still get an
effect
what's more interesting is that this
isn't the only time we've seen this
issue where the person that supposedly
generated the evidence that says that
the drug isn't effective privately says
something very different right the other
time we saw this was the meta-analysis
done by andrew hill so there were two
major meta analyses on ivermectic there
was one from the bird group headed by
tess laurie in britain said ivermectin
is extremely effective at preventing
people from getting seriously ill going
into the hospital and dying
and then the other meta analysis was
andrew hills that said it wasn't
effective
test laurie had a zoom call that she
recorded with andrew hill in which he
acknowledges that ivermectin works and
that he thought he was pressured he says
he was pressured by unitade to change
the conclusion of his meta-analysis and
he hoped that it would be six weeks
before he had more data so that he could
change the conclusion back to saying
that iran didn't work so
it's the same pattern again and again
every time you look deeply into these
supposedly conclusive studies that
suggest it doesn't work you discover
there's some sort of shenanigans going
on where the pi believes something
different than what's in the paper and
the evidence in the paper actually does
suggest that there's an effect so how
many of these do we need to see before
we just realize somebody doesn't want
the evidence to conclude that ivermectin
works and do you think that this is
motivated by a concern that if people
were using ivermectin then they wouldn't
get vaccinated
i'm a little hesitant i think it's clear
what's going on i think what's going on
is so ghastly that for me to say it
raises issues of credibility oh because
that's it
i will i will but you realize
those people when they hear me say it
don't think oh well you can edit it out
if you don't know what right i won't
edit it okay
but i do think
uh pharma is not in the business that
you and i think they're in
right
pharma is in the business of
selling compounds for which it has
intellectual property rights that it can
plausibly argue are useful for
conditions
that
people want treated
right it is not in the business of
making people healthier or safer
and
unfortunately
there were several drugs that were
already out of patent
highly effective and very safe that
would have taken what turned out to be a
many hundred billion dollar new market
and killed it yeah
yeah i mean it's it's it's not a
conspiracy in the sense that it's
there's a profit motivation you're
describing which is that they wanted to
sell a lot of vaccines and they saw
cheaper alternatives
well the problem is
if i'm right
then
it implies a
an indifference to human suffering and
death
that is
uh
pretty hard to fathom
i guess unless i mean i guess the to be
devil's advocates you could sort of say
well
i mean when i look at this stuff like
for example um
the school lockdowns
you know um we're the teachers union in
california which so we had a lock down
you know from 2020 2021 europe was
sending back the kids to school
are the teachers in california were they
indifferent to the impact
that
shutting down the schools would have on
kids
no i mean i think they cared they were
just
over they were just more obsessed with
their own
health and safety than they were and
they make up reasons about how the kids
would be
educated over zoom and it would be just
just the same i mean people find all
sorts of ways to justify
things yeah they want
to do
they do
unfortunately
if you're in the business
of
rapidly generating
a radically novel
vaccine
because you believe that a pathogen is
so
dangerous that it requires extraordinary
investment to shut it down
and in the same breath you are
intervening
in
people's access to a common medication
that many have built successful medical
protocols around treating their own
patients
it's hard for me to imagine
um
the rationalization that would actually
involve those who did it not
understanding that they were condemning
uh
likely millions
to death
what um
help me understand where do you sit in a
relationship there's a bunch of covet
dissidents
there's uh vinay prasad
uc san francisco there's um
uh
charity what's his first name uh you uh
you mean uh aaron yeah eric
aaron carriotti there's jay
bonacarya yeah um
and who else am i missing these are some
of the big robert malone robert malone
garrett vandenbosch
um how do you like ryan cole yeah like
what is the state of play among the
dissidents i mean vinay strikes me
as
fairly mainstream
but he's also harshly critical of the
public health establishment how do you
kind of how do you where do you sit in
relationship to these other
guys i'm very troubled by vinay as much
as
uh
i
want him
to be
a good guy on the right side of history
the way he divides this puzzle makes no
sense to me which is how um
he sees certain issues very
clearly and then other issues
he
which i disagree with him on
um
the wisdom
of vaccinating anyone
right the utility of ivermectin and
hydroxychloroquine so
he doesn't believe him he doesn't
support every mechanic
no and he has so i see him on both sides
of this issue and the places that he's
right i want to cheer him on and the
places where he's wrong i just think how
can somebody who sees part of this
picture so clearly miss so much
and
i'll tell you i mean you know maybe i'm
just around the bend but my sense is
that there is a what i call the middle
ground scramble the middle ground
scramble is on
and the point is
if you
imagine that something
endeavored to prevent the best
treatments from reaching the public in
order for it to sell reckless
and expensive treatments and in fact to
mandate them
well
that thing
needs to be scolded
and all the people who fell for it
need a way out
and so the last thing any of these
people want
is for the dissidents to have been right
right if the presidents were right then
the reckoning that is coming is
yeah
a thing to be feared right
so what they want is somebody nicely
positioned in the middle somebody who
will scold those who did wrong but you
know slap on the wrist level
and will not validate the dissident
perspective so we can still dismiss
those those dangerous people who spread
misinformation right and unfortunately
what i see is been a exploring this
space
and i don't know that he knows what he's
doing but i think the point is there is
a hunger
for somebody who was not part of the
[ __ ] cdc narrative somebody who saw
through it to say oh but those covered
dissidents they were wrong as can be
and the
you know whoever
figures out the dimension of that niche
is going to be very
um powerful and very well rewarded
because it lets the people the
perpetrators off
pretty much scot-free you know the
ill-gotten gains will remain in their
bank accounts
and um
you know
the service of doing away with us
dissidents um will be uh you know
part of the bargain
so anyway i'm not i'm not very pleased
with that middle ground scramble thing i
see it as
its own pathology
but um you know
i think
the community of dissidents contains
some really fine doctors and some very
good scientists and we also you know
have discovered who has the courage to
say what they see and who doesn't
should we move on to the topic that part
of me wants to avoid because uh
i'm
i'm concerned about disrupting the the
the one of me the bonus
as it were but this is with his conflict
and disagreement that'll make it the
most interesting part of the podcast no
i think it'll be good and actually
here's the i'm going to confess
my level of insanity um before we even
embark on this this is a signature issue
for you going back how far
i changed my mind on nuclear between
2007 and 2010 2007 and 2010. so we're
talking about more than a decade of
commitment to the idea that um that
nuclear is an important part of the
solution to our energy problem yes
there's a part of me
that
actually entertains the possibility that
i've seen something in nuclear that when
you hear it and think about it is going
to cause you to change your position
again okay
now i know rationally that can't be
right because you probably know more
about nuclear than i do although i've
spent a good deal of time thinking about
it but nonetheless uh
let's find out where this goes okay you
want to lay out the case for nuclear
sure
um
so let's see
let's start with the fact that nuclear
energy emerges from the lab
so
we
learn that we can split the atom at the
lab level
and
that is important because i think that a
lot of people think that the ability to
split the atom begins with the bomb
program
but the bomb program begins after we
realize we can split the at the atom at
the lab level i think it's also
important because
i think there's still some sense among
some people that we can make nuclear go
away
but if it is when you understand that
comes out of physics out of at the lab
level then there's no way to get rid of
nuclear the knowledge of nuclear fission
of splitting atoms
the first application of nuclear energy
is to
make a weapon
we make two bombs we drop them on japan
so the first application is to use the
weapon to end a war
and
afterwards it's it's a shocking event so
it's a shocking event too and by the way
i'm working on a new book on nuclear uh
specifically on nuclear
it's a shocking event because
of the power
of the just the and it's it's and i
should say too that
we have been people have been thinking
about this power
for
since really the end of the 19th century
it but really with with marie curie and
pierre curie in the early night very
early 1900s with a discovery of radium
there's a sense in which there's atomic
energy and once you release it it'll be
enormous
so there's huge so it's a shocking event
it's before the bomb is used it is
understood by a small group of people as
having significant implications for the
relationship between nations
and that who understood that it would
mean that small nations would be able to
defend themselves from invasion from
large nations
and so this is known as the nuclear
revolution in military so it changes
this old calculation which is that large
states can swallow up small states or
can invade easily and take over small
states so suddenly we realize that small
states can defend themselves
and it also then quickly gets to
appreciating a paradox which is that
there's no way to to properly win a
nuclear war
and that it's two scorpions under glass
in robert oppenheimer's famous uh
picture
and that the only and that um that one
nation that would use nuclear weapons
against the nuclear armed nation
would be
committing suicide
so that i think creates a paradox which
is that
something so
dangerous
could create a form of safety in the
form of deterrence
and this is a very confusing point in
fact my wife said to me the other day
she goes
because when when putin was when there
was a stuff around ukraine and putin was
sort of saying reminding everybody that
we have nuclear that he has nuclear
weapons that any like the us being too
close to him could result in nuclear war
my wife said but you don't think that
that's possible
and i said well sure it's possible and
she said but you you don't think it
would happen i said well this is the
paradox is that if you
if you stop fearing nuclear weapons then
they don't work anymore
and so the reason that nuclear weapons
work to keep the peace is because there
is a possibility that they could
be used
i don't get too far down the track but
so one so one thing about nuclear
weapons though is that they genuinely
pose
something close to an apocalyptic threat
if not apocalyptic
there's a debate about whether nuclear
winter is probable or not but we know
that
full-scale nuclear war between the
united states and soviet union which the
two countries with significant weapons
are one of the only ways that we can
imagine for civilization to destroy
themselves so quickly
so i do think that nuclear weapons
are
uh
do pose a significant threat to
civilization and i also think that they
have
spread peace between nations and that
that's occurred between the united
states and the soviet union
soviet union and china and now we see it
between india and pakistan
and so i think and so that's first
observation second observation is just
the time around nations acquiring
nuclear weapons is the most dangerous
moments and so i get nervous it's when
north korea gets the bomb that everybody
gets nervous but then some years pass
and things stabilize
just to cut to the chase of my book in
terms of weapons i think that it's time
to for the wet for western
the western alliance to have three
nuclear umbrellas rather than one
i think it's time for japan and south
korea to have their own nuclear arsenal
and defend themselves and potentially
australia from an increasingly
aggressive china before china takes too
many small islands
and that is time for western europe to
defend itself and that means britain
uh france and germany
um in terms of the energy so hold on
yeah let's pause there because you've
said a lot and i want to say a lot of
what you've said i don't disagree with
okay um
i do think
you know i would i would phrase the
paradox this way
if we have nuclear weapons
they will be used in earnest and it
could be
um
existential
the fact how do you mean what do you
mean by used uh do you mean detonated i
mean they will be used
aggressively
do you mean used as deterrence are used
the i think the paradox is this the
deterrence works
yes it makes for a more peaceful year to
year things are more peaceful because of
the threat of nuclear war correct but if
you have that as a permanent mechanism
eventually
the um the dice will be rolled in an
unfortunate way and they will be used in
earnest that's not what i and i don't
agree with last words no no i'm adding
that part okay and i think it's frankly
just statistically the case which is
what you know
as you point out if there's really no
threat of them ever being used then
they're not an effective deterrent so
right the fact of them being an
effective deterrent says that there is a
danger that they will be used and then
the question is whatever the magnitude
of that danger is spread it out over
enough time and it says oh they're going
to be used oh i'm not with you in that
last part i know okay i know but i'm
just saying no
i was with you all the way up until that
very last sentence so so and this is a
mirror of where we're going to end up
with nuclear energy interestingly i
didn't see this coming but i i now do so
my point is actually
i think it's just a mathematical
question we agree that they work as
deterrents and that says that we can't
afford
to use them for that purpose
indefinitely you could use them for a
short time and in fact it was pretty
effective you know after world war ii
for for a good chunk of time um and then
this also raises
this raises the specter of my brother's
point uh i don't know if you have you
heard it
yeah we didn't have my brother and by
the way i love my brother i think he's
one of the most insightful people on
earth
this particular point of his is one i'm
not fond of at all okay
his point is we need above ground
nuclear testing in order that people are
reminded
of just how dangerous these weapons are
so that we will not use them
right i don't agree with that either
right well
let's put it this way at the level of
thought experiment i think he's right
which is that just as you point out that
the deterrence um requires the actual
threat it also requires that people
understand how serious that threat is i
don't know how much that is increased by
an above ground nuclear test because
it's not like most people can observe it
we don't need it right
there's sufficient fear of nuclear
weapons and nuclear war
for there to be deterrence in fact i
think that a significant quantity of the
fear of nuclear energy
is displaced fear of nuclear weapons all
right you will find that mine is not um
we'll see yeah we'll see we'll see yeah
um
but in any case yeah uh so you you we've
arrived somewhere interesting you and i
agree on the basic picture that you know
year to year the world is less
uh were
less inclined towards war because of the
specter of these weapons being used um
but that
if they were used in earnest that the
the net benefit might be radically
reversed
right could be yeah
um especially the major exchange yeah
yeah okay
so now let's get to uh nuclear energy
and see where we end up doing right you
want to pitch it oh yeah sure so um
so nuclear energy nuclear energy
is the
controlled fission process to create
heat
to generate steam to turn turbine and
generate electricity but nuclear energy
is also by generating significance of
heat
without combustion
is effectively a way to reduce
humankind's
environmental footprint from energy to
close to zero
so humans use about half of the ice-free
surface of the earth most of that is for
food production
but even food production can become
significantly
uh shrunk at the footprint if you have
sufficient quantities of energy so the
picture here is of gigantic
vertical farming so can i uh
see if i understand this well enough
that i can anticipate the connection
between those yes
and the haber bosch process
radically increased the amount of food
that we could produce interestingly it
is also downstream of a weapons
technology very interesting the bosch
process was invented
uh basically because although nitrogen
is extremely plentiful the accessible
nitrogen isn't and so what uh
haber-bosch
can primarily bosch did no it was fritz
haber um
industrializes it okay so haber figures
out how you can use energy primarily
from fossil fuels to pull nitrogen uh
out of the atmosphere and turn it into
a
compound that is then usable for bombs
because of course nitrogen is extremely
explosive
the same technology then results in the
massive ability to increase the amount
of food we can produce because that
nitrogen works as a fertilizer
and so
i forget what the figure is that
something like a third of the protein in
all of us is actually the result of
haber bosch
recovered nitrogen basically fossil
fuels allowed that nitrogen to be
brought into a biotic
not even a word uh a biotic process to
be made into food which is then
incorporated into us that's right and so
in terms of environmental impacts we
were dependent on manure and guano and
so and there was obviously there were
strict limits in the amount of manure
iguana we could find
but more than that if you have to use
manure from cows or some other animal
species
you are massively increasing the land
footprint so heyribash allows the allows
for a power density
improvement and so from an environmental
perspective energy density and power
density are the key mechanism so if you
shrink
you know if you want to save more
environment then you want to use less
environment and by environment we can in
this case if we talk about land so what
nuclear does is it radically
reduces the amount of natural resource
required to sustain a high energy
civilization
so true sustainability
meaning
meaning a high energy human civilization
plus a planet that dedicates increasing
amounts of landscape and other material
throughput to
nature or wild nature or whatever we
want to be parks
golf courses um would be one that moves
from
energy dilute fuels
wood to coal to petroleum and natural
gas to uranium right
so uh just to put that in slightly
different words um what
haberbash
did with fossil fuels could be done even
more environmentally efficiently if you
use uranium as the source material and
you
use fission to boil water yep um okay i
don't disagree with any of that yes um
uh
so
first of all i wanna
i have my own way of thinking about
nuclear and it okay it involves us
navigating the difference in some of our
terminology i would say
nuclear is not one process it is two
opposite processes
um fusion to me
is the solution that you're looking for
we cannot yet do it in a way that is
productive and we have been decades away
for decades right in other words
it's fusion
compared decisions is so difficult that
we have yet to manage it in a way that
is other than interesting at a research
level
we may maybe close or we may not um
hopefully we're close but the moment we
have fusion power
then
i'm totally on board with that analysis
my concern
is fusion power and in particular i am
most alarmed by uranium right there are
other processes in which fission can be
used to generate energy that reduce some
of these hazards greatly and there are
even some that have now positive
externalities in terms of burning spent
fuel
right so
i am very cautious about anything on the
fission side
but i'm open to the possibility that
there are solutions there that we should
engage and maybe some that we have to
engage now that we have all of the
nuclear
the spent fuel that we've got stored up
all right
is it time for me to
deploy what i think is the argument that
reverses this whole picture sure okay
what should we do with the spent fuel
okay
um
well let me kind of let me address that
but let me back into it by addressing
how i think about energy transitions and
then i want to say something briefly
about fusion
so we
mostly move towards new fuels
because the new fuels become more
abundant and cheaper than the incumbents
now
that's not to say that some amount of
scarcity and rising prices of the
incumbent fuels
doesn't encourage the move to the new
but let's just take the most salient
example which is that the united states
has
reduced our carbon emissions by 22
between 2005 and 2020
uh that 61 of that reduction occurred by
moving just from coal to natural gas
which produces half the carbon emissions
similarly the move from wood to coal
mostly occurred because coal was so much
cheaper and abundant and
more useful than wood there was some
wood scarcity in britain but it's been
exaggerated yeah coal mostly opened up
new possibilities for producing
concentrated heat
particularly the steam engine but even
before that we had process heat so wait
i want to
put in one piece of the puzzle that i
think belongs here
wood
is
renewable
it is also
part of a cycle
right which is to say that to the extent
that what you do is cut down a piece of
forest burn the wood and then that
forest regrows the carbon that's been
put into the atmosphere is then
recaptured by those trees so there's at
least in principle and equilibrium to be
had there right now wood is not a good
fuel it's it is extremely
environmentally destructive to go after
it right um so i'm not arguing it's a
solution but at least the fact of the an
equilibrium existing there is
significant and useful yeah when we
liberate fossil fuels
we're taking eons worth of accumulated
carbon
and releasing it suddenly in a small
number of decades and that is not part
of an equilibrium right and so that is
alarming and dangerous and um i assume
it animates you as it animates me that
that's not a good idea right right
change
yeah yeah so go ahead yeah
so so the energy so energy just the way
i think about energy transitions is that
the main event is making the new energy
cheaper
and allowing it to replace the older
energy
now the that's a little contrary to
conventional wisdom on climate policy
which is to try to make the incumbent
energy more expensive yeah but if you
look at how we actually reduce carbon
emissions in the real world it's by
making the clean energy source cheaper
which is mostly gas
now nuclear
is a bit of a so my view of nuclear is
that it's super young
um people think it's old but that's an
illusion um
nuclear fuel you know uranium as a fuel
but nuclear as a process is very very
young
and the way i'll illustrate this is by
saying that we had a steam engine
that existed about 60 years before the
watt steam engine called the new komen
steam engine that was highly inefficient
because the condenser it didn't separate
out the condenser
so
we really it's revolution in terms of
the steam engine revolution which of
course gives us trains and factories
uh when we have a modest some modest
technical change to the end use
technology which is steam engine
that i think is still a process that
could be occurring with nuclear power
plants but may be stretched over even
longer period so i'm going to agree with
you that fusion will be superior to
fission
i think we will have it i think it will
be i think it is long i think it is much
further away than almost anybody that i
know thinks it's further away i think
it's if i had to guess i would say next
century not this century
um and i would say that i think that
we'll get it
when there's demand for it
meaning somebody really trying to get it
and the reason i think that is because
when i look at other energy transitions
like how do we get fracking
in the united states we got it because
the people because a set of people
really wanted it and they really there
was demand for it there was a high
demand for gas a high price
and the us government really wanted it
and the entrepreneurs really wanted it
so i tend that's how i tend to think
about these technologies is that there
needs to be a demand pull
and a technological push there has to be
some something that will really want the
technology
and there has to be governments kind of
pushing to get it oh now now you've got
me really wanting to win you over
because
the the point then is
uranium-based fission is that an
obstacle to what we really need which is
fusion
i don't think so i think it's actually a
path to fusion
here i'll yeah steel manure i imagine
your argument is going to be here
the reason that you say that there was
demand that
you know we can leave aside whether we
think fracking is a decent technology i
mean i think it is destructive but
obviously it has had a huge upside as
well
both in terms of
our security you know by liberating
fuels where we couldn't get them before
it has made us safer right
and you know what is liberated is
comparatively clean but um
i think part of what's implied in what
you're saying is that it because it was
the same people in the same business as
the fuels that were now so expensive
they innovated their way to this how do
we keep getting fossil fuels out of the
earth and the answer is oh well some of
it's inconveniently trapped you know in
rock strata can we
you know break those strata apart and
liberate it right whereas the point is
there's nobody in the fusion business
right the fusion business is a
speculative business
and
because of that the point is the the
uranium-based nuclear industry isn't
pursuing fusion it's a competitor
right um
so i i don't like to hear that you think
it's it might be next century but i you
know i do think the fact that it always
seems to be a few decades away is
indicative that this is a genuinely
difficult problem yeah i mean it's sort
of based on um
the reason i come to that is that i
think i don't think that there's any
scientific think there's any um
like nobody thinks that it's
scientifically impossible but everybody
under everybody thinks it's
technologically very difficult
and the things in my in nuclear fission
i see a lot of people engineers who
think things are tech should be
technologically simpler and then they
get into them and they discover they're
much more technologically difficult so i
mean our bathroom remodel was a complete
nightmare compared to what we thought it
was at the beginning and that's like a
stupid bathroom right like nuclear power
is
much more complicated and difficult the
fracking revolution was much more
difficult you know it wasn't just
fracking it was that they did horizontal
wells and then they had underground maps
they were able to map
three-dimensionally using lidar and
other technologies so it was a
combination of underground it was a
combination of horizontal drilling
fracking and 3d mapping that combined to
get this really sophisticated
so
okay so let's go let's get to the issue
of the used fuel rods yeah um so so
actually let me put a piece of
information that i didn't know okay
until relatively reactively on the table
but apparently um
fuel nuclear fuel before it goes into
the reactors is
not perfectly safe to handle but it's
pretty close what happens to it is that
in the process
in the reactors itself
all of these isotopes are created some
of them are extremely dangerous things
that were not loaded into the reactors
like plutonium for example right
at the end of this process what you get
out
is physically so hot that it has to be
actively cooled
for something like five years 18 months
18 months yes okay 18 months pools of
water yeah so way to say 18 months
before you can put it into a dry cask
storage correct okay
so we're going to get back to dry
casting storage but 18 months that's
better than five years it used to be
five years i know i got that number from
somewhere
i've only heard 18 months is the number
i've heard okay but yeah now a lot of
fuel rods even at 18 months we just
leave them in the pools
right yes we are not moving everything
to dry cask storage as soon as we could
yeah yeah but in principle you could
move anything you know what actually you
might be around is 18 months the fuels
are in their fission process for 18
months i mean it could be in the pools
for five years i think they're in that
cost for five years and the reason that
they're in the pools for five years is
that the amount of decay heat is so
great that if these things are uncovered
they actually literally catch fire
yeah um the solution to this ultimate
well you have to be vigilant about
keeping them with circulating cold water
for uh
some period of time yet to be determined
maybe we'll
add it to the notes here but i think
it's five years
and then
um you could move it to something called
dry cask storage now dry cask storage we
do yeah it's not a great solution but
it's better in that it doesn't require
any vigilance it's basically
um a steady state in which the
no energy is required in order to keep
the stuff cool it doesn't catch fire
etc so what we've got is a problem where
we've been accumulating fuel
most of the fuel that we've accumulated
is now in the range where it could be
put into dry cask storage i don't know
what the percentage is but a lot of fuel
that could be put into dry fast storage
isn't it remains in the fuel pools well
in the united states i believe so um
that's not my understanding my
understanding is that it all goes into
dry cask storage really yeah i mean
because the pools would get full
pools would be filled and they're not
constructing new pools they're just
moving the so but you're right that so
so
yeah so it comes out of the reactor goes
into the pools and it comes out of the
pools and goes to dry cast storage we
agree that once in a dry cast storage
i don't agree at all that it's fine but
it doesn't require vigilance
it requires some vigilance it requires
that you
protect the site yes right but it does
not require you know the fuel pools will
go dry in a small number of hours if the
power that circulates the water is
turned off this is what we learned at
fukushima i mean yeah well the rod the
the fuel
they didn't lose those uh those fuel
rods they stay they did manage well yeah
i think there was evidence that they
became uncovered through herculean
efforts of very courageous people they
were kept wet and we didn't get one of
these massive fuel pool fires right but
you know
let's put it this way if one of those
pools had cracked
so that it couldn't be filled with water
we would be in a whole different
situation well yeah they'd have to be
put in they'd have to be taken out and
put into cool water and it's not obvious
that you could do it in the number of
hours that you had especially with uh
the tangle that you had after the
earthquake um you know in other words
i think the number of scenarios in which
the fukushima site could have gotten
away from control right where you
wouldn't have had these heroic people
maintaining control over the site but a
small number of a small bit of extra bad
luck would have resulted in the site
becoming ungovernable like chernobyl
uh
chernobyl was ultimately rendered
governable right but the but let's let's
work our way to the accidents let's just
finish the fuel cycle so
um so we have a cycle where the the fuel
rods they they split atoms for 18 months
in the reactor core they come out they
go into pools of water for five years
i think that's probably right um and
then they go into dry cask storage yeah
the dry um
what could let's consider what risks
there are in the dry cat storage for a
minute because let's come back to the
pools which i agree is a sensitive part
of the process
um there they're just these old used
fuel rods that are in cement and con
they're in a steel and concrete at the
site of production
um at decided use at the site of yeah
the site of yeah i see it shane the site
of the fission process yeah electricity
production not the site of the fuel rod
production um
there are some countries that are
like sweden that are now going to move
them into an underground repository that
was a proposal to do that in nevada yeah
as a newcomer to this field i never
understood why they want to do that um
what was wrong with keeping them above
ground
um
so one thing is you ask well what could
could you make a bomb out of the used
fuel rods so it's worth pointing out the
useful rods have been enriched the
uranium has been reached to around five
percent yeah um
to get bomb material they need to be
enriched over 90 percent so we've
already we don't have the enrichment
high enough for the b bombs but plus now
they're
uh
they've been divisions process has
occurred there's still a lot of energy
that could still be released but the
current process is so inefficient that
most of the energy um cannot be released
without what we call reprocessing the
fuel rods the french do that they then
take those used fuel rods and they put
them through
a mile long facility to reprocess the
fuel rods
and from that they were able to extract
more and more fuel
that process is nobody disagrees is more
expensive than what we do but it has the
benefit of creating plutonium which the
french thing can use for their weapons
program we create plutonium just so
there's a lot of mythologies about it
but we create plutonium for our weapons
in a different process yeah um so i will
say although i think the proliferation
issue
is real yeah
almost none of my objection to
uh
uranium-based vision is based on that
yeah yeah okay so we can set that aside
um
so then we're now we're dealing with the
pools issue and the risk of a um really
uh let's call it a meltdown combined
with a fire
where you'd have significant quantities
of radioactive particles
released into the natural environment
outside of containment yeah so um
let's just do a
uh
a proof of concept yeah at fukushima we
had
a triple meltdown
one of those meltdowns uh in reactor
building three
was different than the others it was um
more catastrophic although reactor four
the building got severely damaged the
explosion reactor 3
was different and the likely reason for
that was that reactor 3 was running uh
mox fuel mixed oxide
which actually includes plutonium
reprocessed from decommissioned weapons
so anyway it is on the one hand
efficient to use that material to
generate some energy on the other hand
it creates a worse meltdown scenario
none of the fuel pools so these are
large elevated pools
none of them cracked in any of these
explosions terrible things these were
about hydrogen gas explosions not
nuclear fission explosions well
the one in building three looks to have
been a prompt criticality there does
appear to have been a nuclear detonation
but the explosions that ripped apart the
buildings were hydrogen explosions they
were hydrogen explosions just
so the people who are watching it get it
the idea is that the radioactivity
actually tore apart the water
producing hydrogen and oxygen so
inside the containment buildings you had
hydrogen building up with oxygen and
then it takes nothing to yeah some sort
of ignition
something ignites it and
this left a terrible terrible mess
including buildings that even robots
couldn't go into and last more than
i don't know an hour to
even survey and do cleanup work
anyway so it was a terrible mess but it
was not nearly as bad as it might have
been right had one of these fuel pools
cracked these are elevated fuel pools up
above these reactors right
had one of these fuel pools cracked and
there's no reason other than luck that
we didn't get a crack it would have
emptied of water the fuel rods were so
hot that the zirconium cladding would
have caught fire and you would have had
this radioactive smoke pouring out of
these fuel pools until the fire burned
itself out there wouldn't have even been
any way to fight such a fire right the
radioactivity would have been so intense
that there would have been no way for
human technology to successfully contain
it it just would have had to go out well
right i mean it would have been like
chernobyl well in chernobyl there was a
mechanism and people did die but it was
a small number of people
who died and we were talking about you
know the reactor core not an
accumulation of a bunch of cores sitting
in a pool that would have gone dry now
mind you
it didn't even require a crack in a fuel
pool yeah the power had simply remained
out and heroic humans had not been able
to restore circulation the water would
have boiled off
and the same thing would have happened
it would have caught fire
so
my point to you begins with
the reactors we presently have are
structured in a way that events that are
plausible
could result in something that would
make one of these sites ungovernable and
i don't regard chernobyl as ungovernable
well i i mean what does ungovernable
mean it means
that human beings can no longer remain
on site to do the heroic work necessary
to control the release of the pent-up
fuel well i'm not so sure i mean in
other words i think if the fuel if if
the used if the fuel rods in the pool
were on fire i think that the japanese
government would go send people to put
the fire out firefighters remember so
let's just remember chernobyl yeah
nobody had
an explosion
um
a fire
and
melted fuel
exposed to the uh environment and melted
fuel in the
basement below the reactor you had fuel
rods raw fuel rods
grown by the explosion yeah out of the
building yeah so strewn around the uh
right the environment right and so we
and and so
basically
after that accident
um about 28 firefighters died at the
accident and then let's say another
you know
50 or another
you know another about 50 total then a
few weeks later
then you get so so we in so we have and
some of then you have over a period of
years maybe 200 of the first responders
died and some of them that died in
circumstances which are they drank too
much or they were killed in car
accidents we're not really sure but like
let's say a couple hundred people died
then we had an increase in thyroid
cancer yeah uh about let's say 4 000
uh which is a highly treatable cancer um
you remove the thyroid gland and you
take thyroxine so nobody wants to see
cancer but
a lot of us will get it and if you had
to get cancer it's not a bad one it's
not a bad one
so 4 000
premature deaths
over an 80-year period from thyroid
cancer
no increase
in other cancers
according to the united nations
investigations
yes there's a question about how good
those members are how sensitive those
measures are
um there's also a question
uh let's say that chernobyl obviously
the reactors were very different and
there was a part of the chernobyl
disaster that was very russian in nature
because yeah the
the way the reactor was structured um
was more dangerous
on the other hand
um
what if
a chernobyl-like accident happened at
diablo game
who fights the fire
the firefighters
what if they don't go
well they have to go it's their job
that's like saying um what happened to
nivaldi what happened um what happened
to 911
well we had heroes going into those
buildings but what i'm saying is yeah
there's a question first of all
we know what happened to those buildings
yes
we do not know what happens if diablo
canyon does what chernobyl did we do not
know the psychology of people and who
has what authority to order whom to
fight what fires at what cost right to
their families and
basically
you know let's go back to just a little
bit
i want to address that i don't i don't
want to skip over i want to continue the
chernobyl conversation so with chernobyl
we did have significant radioactive
release
and
i think
what i would say and i suspect you would
agree is that we're not saying that
the radiation released didn't cause
any cancers what we're saying is it
didn't cause enough cancers to detect an
increase over the baseline of cancers
that had been occurring
before that in other words we don't see
an increase in cancers
non-thyroid cancers after chernobyl
to kind of go so as i say that no one
did it just says a lot of people die you
know we have a significant percentage of
people that get cancer and significant
percentage people that die from cancer
so if i did have an increase
it was not detectable at the levels at
which we're able to monitor cancer
mortality
right i would argue that it's a
nightmare scenario in the sense that
what you're talking about
first of all
people do not intuit the difference
between the danger of radiation which in
large measured people are too afraid of
and the danger of radioactive particles
which people are not afraid of enough
in my opinion
that radioactive particles are a
particular medical hazard because
we do not have
evolutionary experience with them and
therefore we do not have mechanisms that
protect us whereas radiation is a fact
of living in the universe and we are
pretty well protected against transient
radiation exposures be below a threshold
yeah though to be fair they when the the
people in fukushima that uh lived in a
province after the accident and who
lived in areas where they had high
levels of consumption of radioactive
particles in their food and diet namely
people the farmers that looked around
there did not have elevated rates of
cancer
according to them uh british medical
journal okay now the problem is that i
have now watched the british medical
journal engaged in code shenanigans i've
watched the japanese government engaged
in all kinds of post fukushima
shenanigans like
adding non-radioactive material to
radioactive waste to bring it below a
threshold that made it legal to burn
transporting radioactive material around
japan to mask the signal of the
difference between the exposed
population and the unexposed population
so the point is look i would love to say
let's just look at the evidence and see
how dangerous these things actually were
but at some level one gets the idea that
lots of people are not really interested
in the evidence being reviewed in an
objective way and when they have control
over what access we get to the evidence
i
become agnostic about how good that
evidence actually is okay well so one of
the the characters in apocalypse never
who i have tell the story of the
evidence
is jerry thomas she's a professor at
imperial college london her mother died
of leukemia she's been very concerned
about cancer
she ran the chernobyl tissue bank which
is a the bank of all the tissues of the
thyroid glands
goes back and forth to you know dealt
with victims of chernobyl deeply
sympathetic person never been
on the payroll of the nuclear industry
independent scholar
and she walks i'll have her walk the
reader through the evidence and the
picture is basically it's not like that
there's no
risk
it's just that these risks are
outweighed by
other risks and people's look in other
people's lifestyles you and i
well not only in other people's
lifestyles but the problem is
we have a human bias issue yeah right if
you have you know
19 kids and two teachers gunned down at
school it captivates the imagination and
we become focused on it if
policy about the quality of the food
that children are eating kills you know
20 times that number every year right we
don't notice it right right and so
there's no question that wrapped up in
the nuclear issue
the nuclear power issue is the question
of
the relative costs and benefits and that
it's hard to look away from 4 000 you
know
deaths from thyroid cancer because we
can say hey those are probable cancers
you know those people died from
something that was spit out of this one
building right we get that we don't get
that
um
the way we generate you know
coal is dirty right right it puts
particles in the air people breathe
those particles they have respiratory
issues you know so
you know a proper analysis would look
downstream of all of these technologies
and it would be dispassionate about you
know yep certain number of people are
going to die as a result of nuclear
accidents that's unfortunate but we have
to compare it to the number of people
who would die from other consequences
right
so i'm not in any way discounting that a
proper analysis might look at a shocking
number of nuclear deaths and say yes but
in comparison to the technology right we
didn't deploy it's actually fewer right
right
my concern and i don't know i don't know
if we're at the place to
position it but um
you still haven't told me what we do
with the waste okay you and i agree dry
cash yeah is better than fuel pools all
right well let me say one thing about
you about the um
there's also i want to say something
about the
deaths um
because i think it's a point of
confusion world health organization says
six million deaths a year from air
pollution
um and then we say four thousand deaths
from thyroid cancer from chernobyl in
both cases we're talking about
premature deaths
and almost all end of life it's the same
as the 400 the famous 400 000 tobacco
deaths a year
vast majority people
it's end of life and so it's a
contributor to end of life not a sole
cause by contrast
105 000 people this year will die from
drug overdose and drug poisonings
instantly right and there's nobody
there's nobody and nobody that says it
contributed they say the fentanyl killed
them it wasn't
their obesity or their cigarette smoking
or their alcoholism it's just the
fentanyl so we have 100 just to put
these numbers in perspective right right
right look
yeah
just to kind of yeah oh i i think this
is a this is very important yeah people
don't do this analysis well in fact this
completely polluted our understanding of
covid you really want to say
how many years of life were lost right
and so the point is yeah you know 95
year old woman a 95 year old obese
woman who smokes
who doesn't covet right it's kind of
like what are we talking about here guys
right i mean you know
it's sad but the point is
we ought to have said well why am i you
know vaccinating this 12 year old
increasing their chance of myocarditis
in order to protect very old people what
society puts children at risk to protect
very old people so yes that kind of
analysis has to be done here
um and we're terrible at talking about
it and the news media particularly we're
going to talk about it in podcasts we
have some time to stretch and do it but
even i when i was early advocating for
nuclear would say air pollution kills
six million people a year and it's not
really correct it's more like you should
and so what i try to say now as i say
according to world health organization
air pollution shortens the lives
of six million people a year now with
covet it's even trickier because you
could say the same thing you say kovid
shortened the lives of a significant
number of people is it really the
language doesn't really help because if
you say
fentanyl shortens the lives of 71 000
americans it misses the fact that some
of these guys were in their 20s right
and they and they could have lived until
they're 100
no we need to get good at this and we
need to start talking about things like
all-cause mortality and years of life
lost and we should reserve the word
killed
for things where
it's like fentanyl killed 71 000 people
air pollution shortens the lives of six
million i think it's the right way to
say it's right okay in fact at some
point this is not the time but we should
talk about uh
early work as a graduate student i
worked on
the
reason that we have evolved to become
feeble with age and it has to do with
avoiding cancer and basically
all of these things um your ability to
repair your tissues is
uh well it's set differently for each
tissue but you basically have an amount
of repair you can do so anything that
expends that
reserve capacity accelerates you towards
death right right um
and so there's a question about how much
of your capacity is burned up by these
things and we really ought to be
thinking in that more integrative i
agree okay all right um
so let's get to the tech yep
um
so
so first let me see let me say before i
say anything about the use the the the
fuel the pools
um
if we think there's a problem with pools
we should fix the pools
today we can
um
i am
um so i'm a heretic of my environment
also because i'm pretty nuclear i'm also
a heretic among pro-nuclear people in
that i am skeptical of
the alternatives to the
water cooled nuclear attack that we have
part of my reason for my skepticism
started in 2015 when i go to china
and we're at a workshop among nuclear
engineers in china about alternatives to
water cool nuclear
and they the daytime they all get up and
give their presentations about how we
can cool nuclear with helium gas we can
cool it with fluoride and beryllium we
can cool it with lead we can cool it
with sodium
and it's all very promising because then
you can't have meltdowns because the
fuel's already melted in a combination
or the gas cooled means the way the
gas-filled plants britain by the way is
mostly carbon dioxide gas gold nuclear
that if there's a loss of coolant the
there's convection heating so the the
fuels don't melt down they just they
just heat the whole plant up and then
the heat dissipates and so you don't get
a meltdown
problems so you're talking about in the
reactor yeah the whole actual building
yeah um so
so then you so that's the daytime then
you get the nighttime we got for for
dinner and since i'm i'm i'm an
anthropologist not a uh
a stem person
the evenings when all the chinese
engineers are drunk are the most
informative parts of the meeting
and i kind of go what's the real deal
and they're kind of like these these
designs are you know really far away and
they're hard for us as the top nuclear
engineers in the world to operate and
then you get to
your average joe operating homer simpson
operating a nuclear plant they need to
be safe enough for okay not home but
somebody
[Music]
nuclear engine nuclear workers nuclear
power plant workers tend to be paid more
than coal power plant workers but they
still need to be you know able to work
in springfield
uh ohio
so i tend to be a technological
conservative in that i have seen a lot
of engineers engineers can be arrogant
and then there's just a different issue
which is nothing to do with that which
is that it's just you don't know what
you don't know
so we didn't know what was going to go
wrong with our bathroom remodel imagine
what happens when you get to a totally
different kind of nuclear power plant so
i tend to want to see incremental
improvements to the water cooled systems
we have
and so if we've got a concern and if we
think there's a concern with the the
pools
um
i'm open to seeing the fixes the fixes
that we've made in terms of loss of
coolant
not necessarily for the pools although
it would probably apply is we've
basically started moving water up hill
so if there's a loss of power
and that's what they've done at diablo
they have big pools of water uphill
but then what you really should do i
mean the first thing is if you have a
loss of coolant on the reactor cores you
need to get water over the rack
cores right away in fukushima for a
variety of reasons
they they did not they should have they
should they hesitated and they should
not have
to pump sea water right because it would
corrode everything it would destroy the
core so it was totally completely
destroyed but they should have been like
that should have been an obvious thing
there's like five other things that went
wrong at fukushima as usual
so it's understandable that engineers
would look for
a different nuclear tech i tend to think
i look at nuclear and i go
this is this really radical technology
it's not even using combustion yeah um
you get to you know
you go from coal to gas it's a big
improvement but you're still burning
something at the end of the day
you get to i look at nuclear and i go
you know
it's like i look at jet planes
jet plane technology jet have not has
not changed fundamentally since 1945
yeah
it's improved enormously but what's
really improved
is the system around the technology so
you see air miles travel graphs air
miles travel just skyrockets
and crash and mortality from jet planes
goes down well what's going on are the
jet turbines
themselves better yeah
but what's really better is air traffic
control maintenance operations we
figured out
all the stuff
that human factors so you look at you
know there's a collaboration at one
point between hospitals and nuclear
power plants
in terms of like human factors and it
was like the nuclear the hospital guys
were like the nuclear power plants are
doing human factors
at whole other levels you know and part
of it was three mile island
was one of the most important things
ever to happen to the nuclear industry
they they went from running the planes
55 of the year which is the capacity
factor to now they run 92 percent of the
year and they just didn't because they
basically eliminated
um
[Music]
they eliminated accidental
shutdowns of the reactors
they improved the fuel reloading times
the second best thing for nuclear was
chernobyl the third best thing was
fukushima
that's a dangerous game there my friend
well except for you kind of go you know
you know fukushima
nobody you know nobody was killed by the
radiation uh that's not true you don't
think it's true well it depends what you
mean by the radiation um yeah lots of
particles escaped yeah fukushima and uh
people will you know die of bone cancer
and we won't detect anything okay in
that sense yeah okay contributed
maybe yeah lots of people will have lost
lots of years of useful life which is
not in and of itself an argument against
nuclear power for a reason i mean like
they did at chernobyl right people were
inside
that guy
with acute radiation radiation although
i'm not convinced nobody did there is
reason to wonder whether or not there
are people absent from those analyses
but i agree we don't have good evidence
don't have clear cables
so you kind of go
so then you kind of go all right well so
then um if you just use the basic world
health organization math
um
my friend the climate scientist james
hanson calculates that nuclear power has
saved again the language we don't have
the right language but has prevented the
premature deaths of two million people
because of preventing ordinary air
pollution all right so i'm now going to
okay lay my argument against your power
out for you and your friend james hanson
who i hope becomes my friend james
sanchez i'm quite an admirer of his
um
here's the problem
what do we do with the fuel
the dispenser okay i think it's best
where it is at the site of electricity
production i see no reason to move it
i
think we will in the next century reuse
that fuel in new reactors that are fast
reactors that reuse the fuel but where
it is now it's the best place for it
there's no need to transport it we can
just keep it on site
yeah you're just it's fine where it
stepped into my trap okay i mean there
was no way out of my trap but you
stepped into it
okay so it's the best place for it yes
it's a terrible place for it okay it's
not saying it's not best okay here's the
thing because we've never figured out
what to do with that spent fuel and it
just keeps accumulating in the drycast
storage in any in any version well the
fuel pools i agree that the pools are
the most sensitive place
the most likely place for us to lose
control of one of these sites which has
not happened yet
it's having a chernobyl
it didn't happen chernobyl
the fires were fought a number of people
died fighting fires doing heroic things
i'm talking about something that would
prevent a site from being manageable
where you would just have to let it
unfold but why would anybody do that
because like when we would have
firefighters be like we're not going to
do our job and put that fire out well
first of all i don't know anything about
the
um
of
firefighters who are downstream
of
the awareness of what happened to the
firefighters who fought at care noble
it's possible that in you know in uh
in the context of certain cultures
that there it is possible to simply
order people to go to their deaths
fighting nuclear fires and and the like
it is possible to reward people's
families
enough that somebody would rationally do
so
but it doesn't mean that i think if
diablo canyon diablo canyon
was to
be in a serious crisis that we
necessarily know what would happen and
effectively what we have to know is that
every single one of the 400 civilian
nuclear reactors operating on planet
earth today that the proper structures
are in place to get somebody to fight
that fire even if it is at the cost of
their life then there's a question about
do we reach levels of radiation so high
that actually it is implausible that you
could fight you know that the fire is
too big and the level of radiation is so
high that you actually can't get anybody
to do the work because it is too
devastating too early okay but so let's
let's deal with the first issue we have
fire so now how many firefighters do we
think died at 9 11. it was was it over
was it hundreds right yeah i believe so
i'm like yeah so so i mean we have
firefighters that um sign up for a job
that is by its nature dangerous
that they rush into the buildings that
are at risk of collapse
they are surrounded by stories of people
dying
we have
militaries
which are formed of young men
that contrary to
uh so their instinct for
self-preservation
die
often fighting to protect you know
afghan girls and we have an iraqi people
that they've never met before right but
there's a difference between entering a
scenario in which uh you feel you have a
pretty good chance of surviving
and a hopeless scenario which is what
happened at chernobyl right people
walked into a hopeless scenario and did
the work yeah right and thank goodness
that they did
um the question is can can we rely on
that 100 of the time
wow nothing i know about humans tells me
that you could rely on that 100 of the
time but then what would the what would
be the specific so in other words okay
but so we could imagine that at a
chemical refinery right yep
um so what makes
nuclear different i mean in other words
why would they be less likely to
well
you know i'm
not certain i know enough about what
chemistry we're doing in chemical plants
but my sense is
chemical plants we have conceivable
protective gear for virtually any
scenario that would unfold yeah so
it would be possible to manage your way
through it but radiation is a different
a different animal altogether in other
words the fact that you can be exposed
to such
huge amounts of radiation that you
effectively fail on the spot is a hazard
well it's it's actually i mean i don't
think that there's there's i mean it's a
it's a hot fire right so the acute
radiation sickness is not happening
faster than the fire
you so you have a let's say you have a
fire um in one of the pools
you send in a bunch of firefighters and
you're like look guys
in what way
um
well i mean
send i mean they're going to be either
the same way you send them into any fire
but are they
shooting water out of hoses into a fire
into a pool that's cracked i don't think
no it'd probably not be water okay
probably some other and probably some
other fire retardant um do we have that
fire retardant that you could pour into
a cracked pool that actually shuts down
that fire i mean it wouldn't be water
right it would be some sort of fire
retardant sure some sort of same thing
they did with chernobyl right um
where they're spraying their spraying
material to put out the fire and to
cover it cover up the radioactive
materials i don't think chernobyl's
issue was a fire
i think it was a fire there were there
was certainly fire yeah that wasn't the
primary issue basically getting the
material back into the core and then
covering it so that it was not emitting
well they put out the fire and then the
days that followed they had um
these guys called liquidators that would
go in for very brief periods of time
double the stuff off and show themselves
and maybe they'd like have a stopwatch
and they would go in and
it is what it is no because a fuel pool
fire is a different animal right if you
had that material on fire from its own
internal heat i don't think there is
anything that you could do or if there
is i want to know what that plan is now
i don't want to find out about it after
some fuel pool has
cracked and dried but do you doubt there
is a plan
i mean i doubt that there's a good plan
i i would suspect the plan is better now
than it's ever been you know we're
trying to [ __ ] okay i i i am entitled
to know it as a person living on this
planet with these reactors but i mean i
would suspect that um it's basically a
plan to get material onto the you the
burning
right uh i want to know i want to know
what that material is i want to know
what the mechanism of delivery is and
how tolerant it is to the chaos of a
one-off accident yeah right something
like happened at fukushima right where
we got very lucky right you had multiple
meltdowns right you had the aftermath of
a massive earthquake right yeah all
sorts of challenges a tsunami that
killed fifteen thousand people instantly
right didn't contribute to deaths but
killed fifteen thousand people right
killed
instantly right right you know
yeah swamped the
generators and all but
i wanna know what those plans are yeah i
want to know what the material is i want
to know are you delivering it by
helicopter if not by helicopter by what
other means what kind of energy does it
require how effective is it how tolerant
is it to the different ways that a pool
could fail how tolerant is it to the
number of hours after the pool has
failed that you get there in other words
how much fire has occurred how much
further damage to the fuel how much
melting all of these things are highly
relevant to whether you can get anything
to stick to these elevated pools to shut
down that fire because my contention is
that what we've got currently
is a system in which we mine uranium
we enrich it
we then put it through a reactor and we
make materials that are
as toxic as anything on earth
and then
we don't have a plan for long-term
storage which means well no we have but
we just agree that we do have a plan for
the long-term storage we're talking
about the pools no no we don't have a
plan i mean the dry cat storage isn't
kind of those those fuel hours and dry
cast storage are not going to catch on
fire no they're not going to catch up
fire but how long do they remain
contained well why is that even a
concern because ultimately i believe
[Music]
if you don't have a plan for long-term
storage and i don't think yucca mountain
is a plan obviously it didn't unfold
that way
but if you don't have a plan for
long-term storage
every bit of this stuff that you produce
is ultimately going to find its way into
the environment and that's my concern
okay but that's a very all right let's
i'm glad we're switching to this so
let's let's agree that um um i'm going
to get back to you with uh and we're
going to look at how do we deal with a
fire at the uh spent fuel pools
and what do we do if there's a loss of
water in the pools it's an interesting
question i suspect there's a very
detailed description but but you've
inspired me to
do it and we'll do it
so let's go to the long-term
used fuel rods in the steel and cement
so we have a lot so we can agree exactly
let's just say yeah
i am quite heartened to hear that you're
a fan of dry cask storage yes and i
think you would join me in saying we are
insane to leave anything in a fuel pool
that is ready to be moved but to the
extent that we have materials that have
built up it is crazy to have it in some
system that requires vigilance when it
could be moved to some system that is
potentially durable
as soon as we can get into i i've gone
to the casks i've wrapped my arms around
them i've held a gagger counter or
yeah next to the them i'm totally
satisfied great so this is this is
something on which you and i are totally
no matter what else we can include
it it makes sense for us yeah to move
everything as soon as it can be moved
into a stable form yeah i can't i can't
imag um if there i don't know why
anybody wouldn't want to do that but i
can look into it
i can't imagine it'd be cheaper to keep
it in the pools than in the dry cast i
believe so it's been a year since i
looked at this but i believe that this
is the reason that the industry hasn't
done it is that it is expensive to move
its dry cask storage but it is in direct
cast storage some of it well i mean
at diablo canyon and palo verde i've
seen it it's in dry cat storage
um
and besides it would just accumulate it
wasn't they would the pools would be
filling up yeah and they can't be those
rods they can't be too close together
right obviously you create yeah
efficiently you create figuring to do
that um my belief is that they are over
packed in these pools um and i will be
very so you're in a better position to
get this information
yeah if there is the principle being we
should get them into the dry cast as
possible quickly
any and any rational plan would involve
okay so let's deal with the rods and the
dry cat storage so it seems like
we can agree that there are dangerous
substances in the world yep beyond the
materials in the dry cast storage um
there are very few things worse than uh
isotopes of plutonium with a two hundred
thousand year half-life um
uh but there's thing we would agree that
there's things in the world that can
poison people yeah and that we would
want to avoid them well but you know
let's put it this way there's a lot of
stuff the part of the problem with these
reactors is that they create this
um
mixture of different levels of toxicity
you know strontium and cesium isotopes
that are
quite dominant in there have a half-life
of 30 years so anyway you get this weird
mix okay but let's say let's say okay
let's say my neighbor's got solar panels
on this roof okay um when they take them
down they put a big cardboard box on the
driveway and they send up the guys to
rip them off
they rip them off the roof they chuck
them in the cardboard box as soon as
they're checking the cardboard box
they're considered hazardous waste
why
because the hazardous metals in them
including the lead for soldering them
[Music]
becomes pulverized and is at risk of
being inhaled
the europeans have solved this by
delicately taking down the fragile solar
panels sent into africa where they use
them for a few more years and then they
go to the non-dumb
and then the and then they sometimes
disassemble them with other electronics
and people are exposed to hazardous
materials
so in terms of risk comparison
the steel cast storage
has less risk of being in the
environment than the solar panels
no no
the question is how long
a
plant let's assume i mean the solar
panels there's no time at all they're
just they're hazardous right away yeah
i'm not
real worried about the solar panels for
obvious reasons it's not that i'm not
worried about
the lead but the point is are these a
significant contributor to the excess
toxicity that we face in modern times
the solar panels are a bigger
contributor than the used fuel rods no
no
this is exactly the problem
um nuclear energy
is
quite clean it is not as clean as the
industry would like us to believe there
are emissions from these plants but it
is comparatively clean while things are
going well right it runs the risk
of being
the dirtiest process on earth all of a
sudden
right and so it does not make sense you
cannot take the instantaneous measure
and say well this plant
but we is comparatively
chernobyl
so but so okay but i'm just saying in
other words
you your question is and this is why i
do think by the way it's displacement um
is that you kind of go what are we going
to do with these used fuel rods over the
long term and i'm like
keep them safe on site until they end up
being reused
um in future reactors
if they do if they don't then they're
just like any other dangerous thing that
we monitor no no no no no no first of
all
we are in far too much danger of all of
the structures that keep the lights on
failing catastrophically i mean the
danger that we run from a solar storm
knocking out a third of the power grid
of north america simultaneously for
which we don't apparently have a backup
plan right that danger is high okay
right basically people would die
oh a lot of huge numbers of people it's
not okay i mean and nuclear reactors
might well
become little nuclear volcanoes in such
a scenario
uh
no if there was a if there's power
outage they would power down
well but they can't just power down
that's the problem is you have to cool
the fuel for five years so the point is
what you need is sufficient power of
governance to deliver
diesel fuel to those reactors in their
shutdown condition for as many years as
it takes to get the grid back up well
years yeah from a quote from a i mean
not years yeah
no yeah i've never seen years as the
estimate do you know why
and this is the craziest thing of all
this tells you how dangerous it is to
depend on government to protect you the
transformers
on which the grid depends cannot be
ordered off the shelf it takes something
like a year if you were to order one now
it would take a year for it to be
delivered so you know the whole but if
the whole the bread if the whole grid
goes down
i'm talking about a third okay a third
of the grid goes down yeah um because i
was thinking about texas um
you know where it's like a cold start
would definitely take
weeks
uh to get equipped to get the whole yeah
if the transformers are fried by a solar
storm you have to replace them yeah so i
kind of go if if we lose a third of the
grid for years
um
yeah the military needs to keep the
nuclear plants operating but like you're
talking about like mass death i'm
talking about an accelerating pattern of
chaos that the military might lose its
ability to reliably deliver diesel fuel
to those generators so then why would
you be so but it's actually like it
reminds me of these conversations where
people are like what if there's a big
earth like one of the big earthquakes
that hits california yeah this one is
far no but in either but in either case
you would be like
there would be a lot of death going on
that has nothing to do with nuclear i
don't know why that that death is such a
focus for you my point is you don't want
a
process that
creates positive feedback where
chaos that would come from the grid
going down would then be compounded by
nuclear reactors that were dependent on
that grid turning into little nuclear
volcanoes well you're saying that you
have a refugee crisis yeah but so you're
saying that if there was um we need to
basically keep the cool water running
through the pools
and like by the way you need to be
pumping by that point like if you're
pumping cold water into the pools
um with diesel generators you're that's
the that's the the power plants power
down
um i have to say i just find it a
strange it's an odd thing to be worried
about when you've got like
like all of civilization is broken down
like why is the nuclear the concern well
first isn't that a kind of displacement
no not not on those not on the slice
first of all you're dealing with an
evolutionary biologist so it's not that
weird for me to think on longer time
scales yeah right
humans all of us
along with every other creature are the
result of a three and a half billion
year long winning streak in which none
of us who are here have failed to
reproduce even once right
so we're here and it's an amazing
bit of luck
the idea that we are playing with
technologies that not only put many many
many people in jeopardy but that
potentially put the entire project in
jeopardy you know the human project
coming to an end
frightens me and even a small risk of
that is something we would have to
engage in very very sober but i just i'm
trying to the risk would be
losing your entire electricity grid no
no no not the spent fuel the the using
the electrons losing the electricity
grid and not having a plan for restoring
it quickly is a recipe for chaos
i let's put it this way yeah if i
compare two scenarios okay one in which
chaos erupts because we have not taken
care of our nuclear grid problem but
there are no nuclear reactors
in our electric grid problem but there
are no nuclear reactors connected to it
and the same scenario in which the
electric grid going down is compounded
by the fact that there are nuclear
reactors that are depending on it right
i far prefer the former scenario right
it is much less likely to turn into an
existential level crisis
if we have only the electric grid which
will be a disaster and thousands maybe
more than that maybe millions would die
right but that is survivable right you
compound that with
these doomsday devices that you've
hooked into a grid that is insecure even
relative to solar storms that are
happening relatively regularly i mean do
you see a device i know that's all
that's prejudicial
i mean we're talking about we're talking
about like like keeping some pools
of we're keeping some pools of water
going right
no we're talking about many pools of
water geographically distributed 60
sites managed
you are talking about pools that have to
be successfully managed by a government
that hasn't noticed the problem with the
electrical grid that it could solve for
a small number of billion dollars and
year after year does not
okay but you trust that government to
keep those pools cool
well i mean i'm trying to like it's like
first of all we're in a really wild
scenario which is that you're asking me
to think of a scenario where electricity
a third of our electricity has been lost
for multiple years is that so scenarios
if i can compel you
i'm just trying
[Music]
a third of the electrical grid and it
doesn't come back up for
five years
let's say
six months okay so six months we have
six months by the way i don't think
there's any scenario that we have
planned for that brings it back up in
six months but let's just be gentle okay
so six months so we have six months to
keep 20 nuclear power plants
uh cooling pools
operating to keep them operating without
a failure long enough to cause one to
drive okay why are you more worried
about that
than all of the other things that could
cause chaos okay in the system
um i'm not saying you shouldn't be
worried about it it just seems highly
like it just seems i'm curious about the
selective concern here's why it seems
like it's being displaced
from apocalyptic concerns about nuclear
weapons as an evolutionary biologist
i am very concerned about anything that
could end humanity
but that way yeah
the nucle the electric grid going down
without nuclear reactors plugged into it
will be a catastrophe
but it's a survivable catastrophe yes
right
that heartens me
the holocaust was a catastrophe
but we survived all of us including jews
okay much better than a scenario that
causes us to blink out so
anytime we set something in motion that
takes a disaster and turns it into an
existential threat to humanity my sense
is hey wait a minute how sure are we
that that's a good idea but how i mean
what but how does i mean it seems to me
you're you're the you're saying that the
that the keeping those pools operating
that the pools
of the cooling water pools of the used
fuel rods yeah
at a time when
for managing those for six months i
don't i'm trying to see how it's an
essential perfect humanity oh be caught
first of all i mean i'm not even sure
the national if they were all on fire
for six months i'm not even sure that's
nice well that we could talk about that
we could talk about and frankly i think
that's actually an open question if you
took all of the spent nuclear fuel and
liberated into the embassy in the pools
not in the because
we've agreed that the the canisters are
fine there's no scenario for those to
catch on fire okay okay let's let's
grant that okay first of all i'm not
convinced that if civilization fails
because of a massive release of
radioactive particles that ultimately we
don't see 200 years down the road the
dry cask storage fails too
but what would that even look like i
mean you just have like no i mean they
can't i mean they look like fails that's
in steel and concrete well it is in
steel and concrete so
and like let's say it was exposed to the
air like what would it do well my point
to you if if you've got something with a
200 000 year half-life in these things
then even if it's 5 000 years or 10 000
years down the road where the thing is
broken open by natural processes
then that's still an issue now it may
not be an issue
from your perspective because i'm just
trying to figure out like what it does i
mean in other words like lead
um is it's not like there's no half-life
it's just perm it's just a permanent
thing
permanent toxins yeah and so i don't
understand even how you get to a
scenario where
the stuff in the like if you break open
all of the the steel and concrete
canisters 200 and also like why are we
worried about 200 years from now hearing
about a solar storm that hits today
right
well first of all just teleport yourself
into my shoes here first okay
my feeling is there's actually a fairly
simple calculation which is until you
can tell me what we do with the spent
fuel that actually stabilizes it so
human vigilance is not required to keep
it from spilling why why why can't why
can't we rely on human vigilance
uh
because the very same people that you
think are going to be good enough to
manage 60 fuel pools that can't
endure a single failure to keep
water on them the same people that you
have charged with the job of doing that
have failed to notice the problem with
the nuclear grid they have failed to
mandate well we'll find out if they have
failed to mandate that all fuel that can
be moved to dry cask storage should be
moved there as quickly as possible right
my point is these people are failing all
the time all around us and it is
bad when they fail at the level of
vaccine safety and effectiveness but it
could be catastrophic if they fail at
the level of nuclear power plants and
vigilance in the face of a totally
foreseeable but apparently unforeseen uh
failure of the experience yeah i think
you're displacing your anxieties about
nuclear weapons and war onto the plants
well i know you think you're not but i'm
suggesting you might be because you keep
you know as we get to the the the fuel
rods in the con in the canisters yeah
like
first of all let's let's let's i'll
grant those right okay let those go yeah
i'm not sure that i should but yeah i
mean i just kind of go i mean i think
it's interesting psychologically because
i hear it a lot who ago
people go well what are they gonna what
are they gonna do like a thousand years
from now to protect people from those
canisters and i'm kind of like
yeah but yeah but here's the thing right
i get why that seems like look what
we're going to do is come up with a
solution good enough that we can come up
with a better solution later i get that
yeah on the other hand we've done that
we've done it with the whip project
in new mexico yeah
and it's amazing oh it's beautiful
except for the
[ __ ] who put kitty literally
oh you should have seen that coming the
cat litter no no i'm not saying that i
mean it's more like it's like how many
how many people die from that ah that's
not the point it is so i need to explain
this to my audience so they understand
why why is not the point yeah you can
explain why okay
it's not the point yeah
um the whip project was
a
salt cavern that was supposed to be used
to store
by-products of the manufacture of
nuclear weapons and so stuff like the
contaminated clothing and other
materials
were put into
barrels
that were moved into these salt caverns
right and where the idea was stabilize
them for 10 000 years right and then
there's a funny question well what kind
of signage do you put up so that people
5 000 years from now know not to dig
here because there's stuff buried that
they really don't want on bury so that's
an interesting thought experiment and
all of that right but and the fact is
people in new mexico fought the whip
project they said it's not good enough
blah blah blah couldn't quite articulate
the argument and then what happens
they run out of cat litter now cat
litter was being used clay cat litter
was being used to absorb
liquids in the barrels that they put in
the salt caverns which is pretty cool
cat litter has
surface area it's useful stuff for
soaking up things
but somebody who
wasn't too swift they ran out of clay
cat litter now my argument would be
there's no way they should have been
using catheter they should have been
ordering stuff that was mandated to be
of a particular nature so that nobody
could possibly have made this error but
somebody was like well we're out of cat
litter hey fred why don't you go down to
kmart and get us some more cat litter
and fred went down to kmart and bought
quote unquote organic cat litter which
is all very funny until you understand
that what organic means in this case is
not that it was
made without pesticides but that it's
made of organic material like wood pulp
from newspapers or wood chippings or
whatever so they put the wood
based
cat litter in the barrel to absorb the
stuff and wouldn't you know it chemistry
unfolded because of course it would
unfold and so there were gases produced
and one of these barrels exploded and
the exploded barrel ejected plutonium
and people were contaminated plutonium
was showing up in their pee and all that
so the point is look you've got a salt
cavern that we thought was pretty good
for 10 000 years except it wasn't even
good for a century
well except for
here let me try to paint a different
picture um manhattan project yep
um
project to make the bomb during world
war ii spread across
multiple sites including hanford and
washington yeah los alamos and new
mexico and oak ridge in tennessee yeah
those sites particularly hanford yeah
are just a nightmare of toxicity
the uranium radioactive material
vibrating underground towards the
columbia world world war two and they're
just throwing [ __ ] everywhere
uranium mining no protective gear yeah
um
fast forward but look at that picture
1941 to 45
and then you look at how they mine
uranium today
how are they operating through power
plants today yeah the qual it's like
looking at
jet planes yeah look i love you i love
your jet plane now no but yeah so so but
just to kind of go so
you know but yeah we had the dreamliner
and they put these [ __ ] lithium
batteries in
and everybody knows lithium when it
combines with water yeah you have
problems you have fires you have jet
planes go down well wait a second i
thought that jet travel had become a lot
safer and yet here we have dreamliners
uh going down yeah and boeing i mean
boeing is now impacted and whatever but
at the same time we go
um
we love jet travel
and the difference between jet travel
and nuclear
i think
is
not the higher mortality because the
mortality is higher with the jet travel
sure it's the fact that
it measured instantaneously yeah okay
but it's the it's the well you're not
kind of pollution then yet but okay um
but it's the association of it's the
reminder that with nuclear
it's opened up a whole new world
of danger of a potential i agree i don't
think it's paranoid a potential for
civilization
annihilation yeah for annihilation and
that's absolutely terrifying at a
species being level beyond
unconscionable it's not our right to
take out the species right a lot of
people who have yet to live who have a
right to live yeah yeah yeah um and so
that weighs heavily on us as it should
but then there's displacement
psychological displacement so on to the
energy and it's not to say there's no
dangers of the energy it's just to say
they're not um
it's not it's not a sweet generous
it's not it's not there's other if the
great if there's a big earthquake a big
one in california yeah
and we have big problems diablo canyon
is going to be one of the safest places
to be in california and if there's if
the grid goes down
i suspect it would be
that the nuclear power plants would
actually be
in better shape than the rest of the
grid and that we would get them up and
running right away i mean look at here
here's another example
russia invades ukraine yeah there's a
fire fight in front of chernobyl one of
the administrative buildings catches on
fire everybody's passes out but the
behavior from both the ukraines and the
russians was we're going to take really
good care of
chernobyl yep um now there's some
evidence that there was some digging on
site i haven't looked into it yet
that may have exposed some of the
russian soldiers to some higher
radioactivity but the interesting thing
about the um and there's a bunch of
nuclear plants in ukraine um but the
interesting thing about the behavior
from both sides is that nobody wanted to
create a nuclear disaster it's in
nobody's interest to create a disaster
yeah yeah and that's a better metaphor
for the situation well look there are a
couple things i got to say to you one at
least i may be the only one but you're
barking up the wrong tree with respect
to displacement my fear is really about
losing control of nuclear material and
the consequences while they may not um
all i can do is take your word yeah on
the other hand i mean there's like i'd
tell you i tell you if you if you'd hit
an actual but you know it's hard to know
yeah it's hard to know i don't think
it's hard to know in my case because i
thought so deeply and you know
i'm not arguing that the answer with
respect to nuclear weapons is clear it
might yeah you know i agree with you and
i've done the analysis myself i believe
that the net impact of nuclear weapons
was probably a reduction in war over my
lifetime and so you know yes i think
ultimately they will be used in earnest
and that that's unacceptable but i can't
say
um well that's interesting to me what
which we didn't we didn't it was a
disagreement that we didn't get back to
right right but but again
my my i have a simple model no no i
don't know i know and we're well look
we've we've covered it but let's come to
the issue of
um
okay well i want to get to well there's
two things there's two questions yeah
one is what is our disagree maybe it's
not it may not be important around you
think it sounds like what i hear you
saying this eating is inevitable that if
you have nuclear weapons they will be
detonated yes so that's the first thing
i don't think so okay i don't think so
but the second issue is what do you want
to do with nuclear energy ah i will do
that one first and then let's come back
that one's easy okay that one's easy i
think we are
spending
far too little
on
nuclear fusion okay and so look i have a
basically
so first of all yeah i believe our
system has to change i'm a
a founding member of the group b
movement
uh i believe that we are looking for a
civilization level change it has to be
opt-in it has to protect human freedoms
it has to be architected to be
evolutionarily stable but
the part of me that is thinking about
issues like this is like how do we get
through the bottleneck of the 21st
century so that we're around three
centuries from now okay so i do worry
about those long-term issues and i worry
about them a lot um so that may be part
of why we aren't seeing eye to eye here
but i would say i mean i would like to
know more about what that is because i
don't know what that is well let's put
it this way
we spent this this statistic is now old
it's probably
uh eight or nine years old now but we're
spending something like 120 billion
dollars a year globally on text messages
right
we could be spending that on fusion and
or not right
your argument is that we're under
investing in fusion and if we pour more
money into fusion then we're more likely
to get fusion sooner
well yes and i know that there's a
diminishing returns problem in there
there's no amount of money for infusion
that causes us to find it tomorrow yeah
right so
i do think we should be spending
tremendously more on fusion i think in
the meantime we should be shifting
everything we do that can be done
electric to electric which obviously
creates problems with limits on things
like lithium but um nonetheless i
believe that what we want is an
electrically powered world to the extent
possible and then we want fusion to be
the plug-and-play solution that takes
all of that electric stuff and doesn't
require us to do anything new with it we
just turn it on right right so that i do
think is the the issue
and we do have to get through
the
failure of governance issue which is
likely to take us out in the meantime
which is part of why i was so
enthusiastic about your campaign for
governor what about that now you often
people that have your view are in favor
of alternative to the existing water
cooled fission nuclear
um let's put it this way yeah i'm
which i'm skeptical but which
nonetheless looks back to the position
cards on the table yeah i don't trust
the nuclear industry at all okay i don't
think we should be keeping the current
reactors open because i think their
designs are all flawed and they do they
are like taking time bombs and i know we
could do vastly better okay right
were
the nuclear industry to be and frankly
you know it's evolution in the market
that turns an industry into a danger
i'm not arguing that they're bad people
but i am arguing that the profit motive
causes the wrong corners to be cut
but were we have some mechanism for
governing
nuclear fission
and we were to upgrade to fourth
generation technologies
liquid salt thorium yeah
you know closed fuel cycle whatever it
is right
there are
things i'm open to an argument about
right how do we how do we get through
the gap between now and the beginning of
viable fusion i'm open to the
possibility that there are fusion-based
answers i don't think they're
uranium-based but i could be convinced
it doesn't uranium the uranium thorium
thing it's not about the fuel it's about
the it's about the coolant it's about
the cooling and
and the
what happens in the event of a meltdown
and things like this so
um i'm open to the possibility that
there are fission-based technologies
though in principle i would rather we
not have to use fission because it's all
too dangerous i think but the uranium
stuff and especially the current
generation of reactors that we have are
my real concern right they are too
dangerous and look so you want to shut
them down
i mean like how quickly would you want
to do that it's like 20 of our
electricity well sixty percent of our
zero carbon it's twenty percent of our
electricity on the other hand we are so
wasteful of electricity that you really
don't need any more power now i
understand that what i'm saying is a
fantasy here but the point is could you
use 20 less electricity if you were just
more thoughtful about your own life yeah
you could maybe you couldn't but most of
us could right so the idea that it's 20
of our energy
um
means well thank goodness it's not more
because 20 is an amount that you could
just be efficient about right i do think
that there is value in alternative
technologies you know wind and solar and
tidal and all of these things no i don't
think it's a silver bullet i think the
silver bullet is fusion
that's what i think okay all right well
let's get to the um uh we so we don't
agree now which is fine yeah but i think
we've achieved disagreements that's the
productive distribution
yeah but we've gotten to the bottom of
it yeah um
what makes you so sure that if you have
nuclear weapons that they'll be used
uh detonate oh i think you're i think
you're sure of it too i think you just
no i guess no no i don't i don't think
so no here's why yeah um you said
yourself that in order for deterrence to
work you have to have fear that has to
be based on the possibility that they
would be used correct so if it's a
possibility how long do you have to
extend the time before that possibility
becomes probable
it's xeno's paradox never means like no
it's not you just i mean why no because
of that doesn't mean this happens how
low can the risk be and still function
as a deterrent
[Music]
how close to zero can you get without
losing the details well so first of all
i mean it's worth pointing out that it's
an unresolvable it's not something that
you and i are going to muster any
evidence right no it's a result it's a
thought problem yeah um it's a thought
problem i mean it's an interesting one
because i've never
i i it's in the literature like this is
all the books basically they've ever
been written on the bomb um
it's in there there's a lot of people
that say it and it always struck me as a
statement of faith rather than a
statement of what that uh my statement
of math
but it's not math i mean math
it's a statement of if there was a one
in a billion chance of
a nuclear exchange
would it function as a deterrent
i think it's higher than that yeah how
high um
it's fair i mean look we're just not i
think i think there's a risk of um
scientizing this and um and giving
creating false precision by quantifying
it no no it's literally like it's kind
of like um look i'm not making an
argument that i know or that the number
is unstable enough to estimate my point
is if the number is
not zero half a percent a year
we're talking about a very short ride
right how many years do you get to play
that game yeah well let me let me choose
another piece of this
let's say so the two countries that uh
two i would say two countries that are
most at risk of nuclear conflict and i'm
not alone in this
um or india and pakistan yep
um
they get into
so first of all they keep fighting wars
and the number of people that die in the
worst goes down yeah
and um recently there was a there was a
you know a battle between india and
china
and it was like
like
a joke like in terms of because both
sides are like we don't want this to
escalate right so but let's say it did
and you had a nuclear exchange between
india and pakistan
why do we why do we think it would a
escalate
beyond cashmere oh it might not it might
not yeah so in other words it's it's
actually i think it's important because
um
there's sort of a common idea that if
anybody use and i actually there's a
concept called nuclear taboo yeah which
is that
uh which i i agree exists which is that
leaders um
actually don't want to use nuclear
weapons because if they do they would
violate a taboo
now putin did violate a taboo by
invading ukraine um and he's being
punished for it but it's not
inconceivable that you could imagine
that in 10
20 years
that europe and russia would be
back to where they were in 2021 yeah um
but there is an argument that if they
use the nuclear weapons they would be
more like nazi germany
in their
ostracization
so but the but i think part of the
nuclear type that i don't agree with or
that's part of that story which is that
if nuclear weapons are ever used they
would set off a chain reaction and i
think that chain reaction stuff comes
from
the apocalyptic
mentality which is more like no if
nuclear this in vipin narong who's a
professor at mit who i rely on a lot for
nuclear games
you know playing out games he thinks
that if a nuclear weapon were used the
whole world would just everything would
come to a halt and that everything would
be a huge effort to basically prevent
escalation
i tend to think that's true i'm not
saying it's a guarantee against it but i
think that there is a non-apocalyptic
scenario for nuclear weapons i don't
love it i'm not promoting it i don't
think we should um
i don't think it should reduce our fear
of it but i also think there's a risk of
thinking that any use of nuclear weapons
would necessarily escalate yeah i'm not
i'm uh agnostic about okay i think
there's a possibility that once you know
let's put it this way everybody likes
being in the club where they're from a
nation that has never used these things
right we're the only nation who has yeah
um and as soon as that
number of nations that have used them
goes up i think it does do something to
the taboo but no i don't necessarily
believe in fact i don't i would expect
probably not that if somebody launched
nuclear weapons that it would
necessarily result in you know an
exchange of everything we got yeah yeah
yeah like russia could use tactical
nukes in ukraine and i don't think the
united
by buying moscow right
yeah yeah yeah okay i think that's
pretty cool so we're agreeing on that
yeah um so um
well to recap i mean it seems like
we have an open question around what
happens to the
the
the cooling fuel rods in the pools
and you've inspired me to have a better
answer than the one i have right now
and we
uh we have a disagreement about what we
should do with today's nuclear plants i
think we should try to make them safer
and better and expand them and you want
to you would like to see them if not
shut down overnight
phased out and more money put into
fusion well i would like to see them
phased out
[Music]
i would i'm willing to entertain the
question of whether or not there are
a
4th gen nuclear solutions that are worth
utilizing right but ultimately i would
like us to have our eyes on the prize
which i believe is fusion yeah i would
like us to prepare for a fusion world by
moving you know how much of a hardship
is it having an electric car
my feeling is it's kind of awesome you
can say the same thing about motorcycles
as far as i know you can't say that
about planes you can say about boats but
there's a large fraction of the world
that could be rendered
electric
and then the point is whether that's
fourth gen it's tricky with lithium but
yeah well we have issues we have big
issues right now we have big issues i'm
not already might be more hydrated i'm a
little bit more like a hydrogen i think
i'm uh i think hydrogen was early not
wrong my view towards hydrogen is
similar to fusion which is that i think
we'll have it
just interesting i was i was a fan of
hydrogen i must say my um excitement
about it dropped when i saw elon is uh
doubtful about its utility i would love
to get you two in a conversation yeah
about about helium i i yeah
about hydrogen yeah yeah yeah
but he has a big lithium problem right
now yeah you know huge looking problem
um but let me let me uh come let me come
to this other uh question of climate
which is
um i think that there is a trade-off
then in terms of nuclear acceptance and
climate
alarmism yep and that a more consistent
position
um
ironically
and i think it's proof that people are
not consistent in their views
climate
alarmists
should be more pro-nuclear oh i i have
heard this argument yeah from you and i
don't disagree yeah but that climate
skeptics
would be um
much more comfortable being anti-nuclear
but they line up the opposite right
which which means that there's something
else going on and it has to do with
i think deeper worldview issues right
around
trusted institutions around energy
abundance around system about belief in
the system
and so your views i think i think you're
more um
skeptical of the broader system that we
live in of the civilizational system
than we live in and i mean that that
part of me is it seems like there's part
of you that is the only evergreen
part the the the tradition you know the
traditional environmentalists
you mean yeah yeah well yeah but i mean
there's i think there's a i think you
have a um i mean it's totally respectful
like you have a kind of um
uh
skepticism of
our symbols of our high energy
civilization
that is
is is very mainstream on the left wow
yeah i have a
uh healthy respect for unintended
consequences which is often not a
feature of the left right the left tends
to be very excited about solutions and
under aware of the danger of
consequences it goes the other way with
nuclear the left has traditionally been
anti-nuclear um but again
i don't even consider myself antinuclear
i consider myself radically pro-nuclear
as long as we're talking about fusion
yeah yeah um but i mean i kind of look
at i mean i wonder if you would agree
that there's that if i were to look at
your thinking
that you've got a skepticism of our
system that extends towards vaccines
nuclear fission
um
the electrical grid
um deep ocean drilling uh uh-huh
you know credit default swaps and
virginian markets yeah let's put it this
way i i think i have a very
rational approach to this which is i'm
watching the scale of the disasters that
we inflict on ourselves get larger over
my lifetime i'm watching the number of
people
and the interconnectedness of those
people go up in a way that is clearly
dangerous
and i'm trying
to
look i think yeah if we recognize the
size of the problem we are creating for
ourselves
then it doesn't become a world of
austerity on the other side of it it
becomes a
uh a renaissance
right where suddenly there is a lot to
be done upgrading our civilization so it
is no longer rickety and fragile
retooling it so that rights are
protected in a way that we can live well
yeah live lightly upon the earth but
it's a small but it's more small it's
beautiful
it's more of a small as beautiful vision
than a high-energy
civilization vision no i don't think
that okay no look i'm not no you're not
a big decentralized
well let's put it this way i think we
i want everything that can rationally be
decentralized decentralized but i think
there's an awful lot that has to be
governed at a higher scale okay
you do oh yeah okay like because i mean
the way i think of it is
um
uh
economies of scale
um where you have higher levels of
economies of scale and centralized
production allow for more distributed
consumption meaning
we can reduce the cost of food and
energy and products when their
manufacturer is more centralized
yep uh look i think we've got you know
my dissertation work was on trade-offs
and i think yeah the tensions between a
lot of competing concerns yeah when it
comes to the governance issue i
subscribe to something that i've
borrowed from the catholics
interestingly which is
a
principle called subsidiary which is
everything should be governed at the
lowest level that it can effectively be
governed yeah and for some things that
happens to be global but it means that
you should not default okay
you know you're more flexible than than
traditional greens would be i'm of the
same i think i like that yeah that's
cool i'm the same way
um
now but what about for for production is
production governed if it's
energy or of energy and food and
products let's say well elements of it
need to be governed right it's really
easy to externalize harms you know yeah
you know nicotine yeah yeah regulated
right so there's stuff that i want to
see forbidden because it's too damaging
to contemplate yeah right that can't be
done locally yeah um but frankly i you
know again i want everything as low
level as possible but there are certain
things that only the global level will
do and that frightens me because at this
moment i'm watching a push towards
global level governance that i think has
very little to do with externalities and
protecting us and has a lot to do with
centralizing power yeah so i'm
sympathetic to the idea of hey nothing
about global governance but on the other
hand we're
messing with global processes i mean
it's interesting because of course let's
come back to the code just to come back
to the covet stuff because there's a way
in which there's certainly an argument
and i'd be curious if you disagree
that regardless of all the stuff that
happened
nations and states
that they decided how to respond to
covet
based on
california like in other words
california culture determined how we
responded to covid more than gavin
newsom
and the swedish culture determined is
why they had a different response to
kovit than say
[Music]
germany
or south korea that these things come
from within they're not imposed by
they're not opposed by
who has less of a role than we think and
culture has more of a role unfortunately
somebody made it virtually impossible
for you to get ivermectin even though it
might have been just the thing to
protect your family is it hard to get
yeah very okay it was confiscated at the
border yeah um your pharmacist that your
doctor could say yes this is what you
need prescribe it and your pharmacist
would refuse to fill the prescription
they made it extremely difficult but
whether or not there were school
lockdowns or school closures yep came
from with them there was certainly a
uh
patchwork
of different reactions across the
country but certain things were
centralized like thou shall not have
ivermectin okay yeah yeah so it's
complicated yeah
well brett
what a fascinating what a wonderful
conversation yeah this has been a great
conversation i'm glad we did it me too
um and uh
i do think i'm very curious to circle
back after we have both brushed up a
little bit on the places that we
recognize we're a little hazy yeah
because well frankly what i hope
is that people watching this
conversation
somewhere in this they will think huh
wouldn't it be cool if governance
sounded like that on the inside people
comparing perspectives hearing each
other out realizing what they don't know
rather than what clearly does happen
which is people who have a financial
interest are the only people in the room
and their blind spots are ignored
because it's uh yeah you know the way
they don't trust uh they don't trust the
deliberation right um and they don't
trust uh i think the the
yeah the political leaders don't trust
that they could say something on a
podcast
and um and then have a different view
and some other yeah in some other
contexts people at williamsport said to
me and i took us a comment when it was
like i can't see gavin newsom down with
joe rogan for three hours and being able
to right have the conversation i was
with um adam corolla
who's a you know sort of a center right
you know talk show host in l.a and talk
for like an hour
and he they were just like it's so
different from when gavin newsom came in
it was just trying to like
repeat his talking points in different
ways
but there wasn't even any
any curiosity or
well
you know what michael kinsley
said
uh he defined the term
he's a
gaff is when a politician tells the
truth yeah right and so the problem was
sitting down with joe rogan and the
whole beauty of joe rogan or not yeah
old beauty but a large part of it is
that you've got a you know an open
conversation nobody including joe knows
exactly where it's gonna head right and
so the point is you can't do that on
script for one thing it would be deathly
boring yeah and for another thing um
people
talk when they're not
faced with a list of talking points that
they're supposed to get through and so
yeah gavin knew some sitting down with
yeah
but maybe not but then again i didn't
make it into the run-off so maybe maybe
the lesson is that that's not how
politicians are able to do it well but
that's just the thing right
those of us who see the problem with the
duopoly
need to level up strategically we need
to figure out how to confederate because
well in some ways somebody needs to yeah
well we'll need we still need somebody
to prove
the possibility donald trump proved the
possibility yeah i guess so that's right
and i guess to be fair or some amount of
the chaos was him thinking out loud
right
i mean look
it was like the speculating about
solutions to covet
right you know i mean some of you know
some of those things he was right about
yeah clerk when he was right but the
drug became politically so toxic that
nobody would touch it
um but you know the thing is
trump proved it was possible to beat the
duopoly but the personality
characteristics that allowed him to do
that were exactly the ones that should
have kept them out of office
right so what we need is somebody who
can learn the lesson
of
trump having beaten the duopoly and
carry
um a character
that is capable of handling the
responsibility of the office
uh along with them
and you know i believe it's possible i
believe the number of people who can see
the necessity for this is going up
so i hope you're right brother yeah amen
to that all right it's been great it's
been great brett um pleasure yeah thanks
for being pleasure i'm glad we finally
met and i look forward to the next one
me too all right that's great be well
everyone
[Music]
[Music]
you